Hello freaks. Fuck's going
on? Did we sneak up on you?
I barely tweeted this one. Tweet
this one just moments ago. Um,
this episode is brought
to you by Ziprecruiter.
Ziprecruiter is a one of our new sponsors.
And what it's going to do is allow you,
if you're hiring to find
a lot more job candidates,
great job candidates by posting
your job on over 50 plus sites,
including craigslist, linkedin, Twitter,
all with a single click
posting in one place.
It's just not enough to
find quality candidates.
And if you want to find the perfect hire,
you need to post your job
on all the top job sites.
And now you can with ZipRecruiter
with just one click, 50 job sites,
including craigslist,
linkedin, and Twitter.
All will have your job up
there with a single click.
Uh, in this day and age, it's
beautiful when you do things like this.
I love when someone comes along with some
sort of technology that allows you to
consolidate, can find candidates
in any city or industry nationwide,
any industry.
What about Ninjas of the hiring?
Just post once and watch your qualified
candidates roll into ZipRecruiter's.
Easy to use interface,
no juggling emails or calls to your
office quickly screen candidates,
rate them and hire the right person fast.
Find out today why ZipRecruiter has
been used by over 200,000 businesses.
And right now my listeners, that's a
lot of businesses, 200,000 do they?
That's ridiculous.
And right now my listeners can post jobs
on ZipRecruiter for free by going to
ziprecruiter.com/rogan three we all love
free at ziprecruiter.com/rogan one more
time.
Try It for free.
ziprecruiter.com/rogan enjoy it and uh,
cut to the chase and hire the
person you're looking for with
ziprecruiter.com/rogan we're also
brought to you by draft kings.
Hello fantasy football dorks.
Football is back and draft
kings.com isn't fucking around.
draftkings.com is America's favorite
one week fantasy football site.
And you get get your piece of $5
million being awarded this week.
That's what, that's some ridiculous
shit. They have real money.
Like I thought fantasy football was,
you know,
just a bunch of guys having a good
time. Being silly. There's a lot,
there's a lot more involved in it.
I have a championship belt. I'm, I'm a
calm the comedy store fantasy champion.
I don't talk about him. Sort of a
closet case, but you don't eat that.
You don't think it's serious. I have a
championship belt Joe who made the belt.
Uh, the commissioner of the
League. It has the big comedy.
It's all gold and black as a goal. If
someone spent money on those, yeah,
we all threw in an extra or 20
bucks and it's like $200
belt. It is awesome. No.
Um,
if you lose,
do you have to give that belt up or
do you keep a copy of the belt forever
because you were the champ?
Unfortunately our league isn't that luxury
to where you get to keep a model belt
that the Belko sign to the next winter.
Yeah,
because everybody always wonders
that like with boxing matches,
like how does that work? Does a
guy get the belt? You get a copy,
your own Belks guys keep a belt.
If you were the champ,
you go over like sugar ray Leonard's
house. He's still got the belt.
He's not the champion anymore. But
the belts Dylan his house. Yeah. Hmm.
They give you a replica
works that way with program.
They should give you the real one,
the replica that we should be a new one
for the new champion. Hey gree. So I feel,
uh, so if you're one of those guys, one
of those Tony Hinchcliffe type characters,
we got away to take
shit to the next level.
The next level with draft kings.com
you've already scouted players for your
season long team. You turn that knowledge
into instant cash, ladies and gentlemen.
Mostly ladies. No, what's the gentleman?
Heather? I need women at all that are
in fantasy football. Draft Queens.
There's always those chicks like, um, uh,
Amy Schumer had a bit about it on her
show about like girls who can hang and
it's so true. There's always
those girls that, you know,
they had dapped they become one of the
guys are Tiana. Is she one of those? Oh,
she's huge into it. Big Time
into fantasy football. Yeah.
She's in multiple leagues. That's trolling
for Dick. I know what she's up to.
I'm not hating.
Last year,
one player turned 11 bucks into 4,000 in
one weekend and I say that with all due
respect. I liked Sarah.
She's awesome. Um, yeah.
One Dude seriously turned 11 bucks into
$4,000 in one weekend and another player
won $1 million in one day
playing fantasy football.
Awesome. Fucking say that again.
Some asshole when I'm not,
I don't mean ass all like,
I mean asshole.
Like I would call myself
an asshole person.
Won a million bucks in a fucking
day playing fantasy football.
That shit's ridiculous.
Play daily fantasy along with your
season long league at draft kings.
Draft kings.com is where it's at.
You dirty fucks.
They're crowning millionaires
all season and you can be next.
Go to draft kings.com
entering the Promo Code Rogan.
Get a free entry into the week,
one of a into the week one
$5 million kickoff bash.
I'll say that again.
Go to draft kings.com and enter Promo
Code Rogan and get a free entry into the
week.
One $5 million kick off bash,
draftkings.com bigger events,
bigger winnings and making fucking
millionaires. Jesus Christ. Tony.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
Ridiculous winter in the Codeword Rogan
for a free entry now@kings.com all
right, and we're also bought to you last
but not least by onnit.com that has o,
n n,
I t.
We are a human optimization website and
what we strive to do is find the best
products online when it comes to that
pertain to health and fitness and and
improving your physical strength,
your mental wellbeing.
We just find the coolest shit as far as
the coolest technology that is available
today for strengthening the mind
and body human optimization.
That's our idea.
We sell strength and
conditioning equipment like
kettle bells and battle ropes
and steel maces along with videos
on how to use those fucking things.
So don't get hurt. I've said it a million
times before, but please start off slow.
Haven't worked out before.
Don't get crazy and decide you're going
to be the rock because he'd been going
to the rocks Instagram and
seen his workouts and go,
I'm going to fuck up you like the rock,
bro. I just started working out again a
month ago and take my approach people to
seven minute workouts a day. That's the
way to not get hurt. You could do it.
I did want to do it nice and slow.
You can get a workout in and seven hours,
seven minutes. My hemp force.
I use one scoop of chocolate,
Hem Force One banana,
some frozen pineapple from the freezer.
One scoop of peanut butter pack an
extra protein, little bit almond milk.
Good bye.
I got Tony.
I've got Tony to eat some meat this
past weekend and I don't mean my deck.
I mean I got him to eat. He ate
a piece of beef. Did you love it?
Was it the best tasting
thing I was eating?
What's not told in this story is that
in front of me I had three jumbo grilled
shrimp, a crab cake and uh, and uh,
Sam and that had crab meat on it.
And it, you know, it's all amazing.
Food is great. I love the
whole food. Honestly, the,
I love steak always have it. Couldn't
quite compare with what I ordered,
you know what I mean? But that's
what I like. I eat what I like.
I love steak point is Tony ate meat
for the longest time until he's been a
vegetarian sort of. You eat fish. Yeah,
I remember I was there one day where you
ate something you weren't supposed to
like a like a muffin
or something like that.
How you ended up puking
or something. Anyway, this
episode is brought to you by on
a.com what an awesome story,
Brian.
Oh and and it uses the Codeword Rogan
and you'll save 10% off any and all
supplements@onnit.com and right now,
as of this moment,
there is still what it is, 1227 Pacific
time on September the fourth Thursday,
September the fourth there's a 72
hour sale going on it on at 15% off of
everything in the store.
If use the code word CEP 72
that's sep 72 there right now.
As of right now, 23 hours,
32 minutes and 41 seconds.
So I'll go there and do that and get on
it. And if you're catching this later,
the codeword Rogan is always good
for 10% off any and all supplements.
Boom shall luck. Luck. Boom.
That's Tony Hinchcliffe
is here.
Why fuck over around.
Tony and I will be at the Ice
House comedy club next weekend.
September 12th and 13th that's
right. Freak bitches. New Material.
Rolling out. Preparing
the next hour. What?
Cue The music
Rogan experience. Try by day. Joe
Rogan podcast by night all day.
Good.
Google Mowgli.
Tony Hinchcliffe a world tour.
We've been on young man. Yeah,
we've been everywhere. We've traveled
the globe. We've extended our reach.
We've done sets throughout the lands.
We've gone from the high of the rocky
mountains all the way to a hockey rink in
the middle of Canada. We did so
much the past couple months. Yeah,
we did a hockey rink and we,
me and Bryan County did a
goddamn hockey rink in Canada.
Like what a stereotype way up there too,
man. It's two hours north of Edmonton.
Yeah. Yeah. What was the name of
that town again? Lloydminster.
Lloydminster Nice folks.
Great people. Great people.
A lot of people talking about how they
drove three hours from the north and
yeah,
it was,
that's what happens when you do those
middle of nowhere shows you get access to
a bunch of people that ordinarily they
just can't physically get to you in time.
Right.
It takes too much time.
I talked to this one duty drove 18 hours
once to a show. Wow. Yeah. That's a god.
A God damn responsibility when you're
telling jokes to a guy who drove 18 hours.
Yeah. That's, that's uh, I'm
glad you told me after the show.
Tell me before the show, I'd be like,
fuck, I can't even do new shit now.
I've gotta give this guy some fuck.
I gotta throw some heat.
1818 is a long trip. That's a
hell of a trip. But yeah, dude,
we, we'd been everywhere man.
Those, uh, those gigs up in Canada,
number fucking bad ass.
We went from one place,
which is in the middle of the nowhere,
which was a hockey rink to
that theater in Vancouver.
That was just fucking incredible. Yeah.
It was like the perfect contrast. Yeah.
Like three or 4,000 seat crazy
theater with big fancy chandelier.
So it was like game of Thrones. Yeah. And
it was right to do it the right way to,
we did the hockey rink first and
then the Nice theater second.
If we did it the other way, it would
be depressing. Yeah. Toto was like, oh,
it's over. Look at us. We're in a fucking
hockey rink now. Yeah. Joan Rivers,
just a Oh yeah, that's a
rough one. Yeah. So, uh,
rest in peace. Joan Rivers,
that chick, you know, agree
with or not agree with her.
I mean,
a lot of people were mad at her about
her take on Gaza and the whole Israeli
thing. She's Jewish and she's
old. You know, she was, but uh,
she was a real fucking comic. Real comic
will ever meet her till the very end. No,
I was supposed to do her show,
man.
I was supposed to do our show where I lie
in bed with her, like in bed with Joan.
Right. Yeah. Um,
that would have been the
first time I met her. She has
like a podcast that she does
from a bed and you know,
people climb in bed with
her and you tell your jokes.
You might still have a chance if
you make it over there and then
you start of a
good excited on the too soon.
Joe Can, I always love that.
I can't believe you did it. It's my
favorite thing. Actually knew her.
Her daughter.
Yeah.
Pretty well though. Nope. No,
no, no. Never met her. No, no,
never met. I might've said hi to
her once at a place. Maybe I'm not,
never talked to her though. Um, that's um,
that's rough stuff man.
But you know, 81 years old
career, I mean she, you know,
she was like Carson's favorite.
Yes. Shouldn't have some
falling out with Carson. Yeah.
Cause she took a gig going up
against him from Fox. He was on NBC.
She took the 1130. He built her,
he was, she was his guest host.
And he was really offended when she
went against him competing and ratings.
Yeah, I dunno man. Uh,
I feel like, you know,
I feel like that's unfortunate,
but the whole paradigm of television,
like having to watch things at the same
time, like having an eight o'clock show,
you know, Mork and Mindy is competing
with, you know, Blah Blah Blah.
That's on an another time.
Whenever you have that,
you're going to have these sort of
competitive type issues. It's going to be,
it's going to be gross.
That's the beautiful thing
about the Internet. You know,
like when it comes to
like podcasts and shows,
nobody tries to like compete with anybody.
Nobody tries to keep like guests
from going to other podcasts.
No one does any of that.
Yeah.
Well,
when Joan was competing with Johnny,
I'm pretty sure there was
just a regular flat screen.
I'm pretty sure that was just like three
or four channels at the time when those
two are competing. So it's definitely
a whole new age, you know what I mean?
Yeah. Yeah. There was nothing
man there you had like,
you didn't even have Fox back then.
You did ABC, CBS and NBC and that's it.
Yeah. What a fucking
monopoly, Huh? Oh, insane.
They had America's mind and ears.
Yeah.
And the in the,
in America,
if you wanted to find out or be
entertained by something else,
you had to go find a book
or make your own movie.
Wow. Isn't that amazing? Yeah.
When you really think about it,
the numbers that they must have had,
like during the happy days,
like when happy days was a hit,
they must've had like 30 40 50
million people watching. Right.
Seems like it must be much more than
they have today because of the options
today are so huge.
Yeah.
I don't think they can get one person to
watch as many as it as much at one time
would have. Yeah. It's amazing that you
still have network television really.
If you really stop and
think about it cause cable,
they can kind of do so much more.
Yeah. Like even if they don't swear,
I think about like the shit they
got away with on breaking bad.
You could never do that on NBC.
Right. They would never let you.
You can never have like open drug
selling and using and murder and all that
crazy shit the way they do
it. Yeah. Well he tried.
I do believe he pitched it to somebody.
I can't remember whether
it was network or not,
but it definitely found its home
where it landed. AMC, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Meanwhile, nobody had
watched anything on that network before.
There was no like one show that
everybody tuned into on that network,
but some network did turn him down for
that. Imagine being those executives like,
oh gosh, I wonder if that's true. I
wonder if they did turn it down. No,
I know. I know for a fact. I
can't remember which channel,
but somebody turned down breaking bad
originally. Vince Gilligan pitched it.
I can't remember whether it was
network or or Fox or FX or something,
but somebody turned that down.
Breaking bad. What a dummy. Yeah.
OOPS, big. Whoops. I'm watching the
show. The strain. Have you seen that?
That's the Benicio del Toro not been.
He showed delta are where?
Mo Del Toro,
a production of a,
it's a book that he wrote with this
Guy Chuck Hogan, some vampire book,
but it's super fucking gory.
Like really fucking gory.
And when I'm watching it like that,
like along with walking dead,
which is obviously really gory too, you
could never have those. I'm like NBC.
They would, they would, they would have a
shit fit. Right. But you still have NBC,
you still have CBS,
you still have ABC.
There's people that still
want to watch those sitcoms.
Like they still have a hold
on a certain type of show.
Like especially like network sitcoms.
Like that's their shit.
Those like those cameras, sitcoms
where they have an audience, you know?
Well those are the channels now networks,
just the channel that
like people put on in,
leave on and fall asleep and walk around
the house with that on. It's not really,
like know, there's no real passion
behind me. Like NBC. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. It's um, I don't want,
I wonder what they could do because it
seems like there's just too many options.
If you had to like a regular night.
I mean,
imagine if you had like ABC before the
Internet and you watched this thing come
along and then you watch all these cable
companies come along and put you on ABC
in 1980 and you just,
you know,
chilling on a fucking yacht out there
in the middle of the Pacific smoking
cigars saying,
we've got an made.
This fucking business is locked down,
and then all of sudden this creepy thing
called cable comes around this table,
but things were never going to take off.
They can swear. What can they swear?
That's the thing called the FCC, right?
Yeah. That's what people don't know.
They could do whatever they want on cable.
That's why comedy central has
uncensored content late at night.
If you tune in to comedy
central late at night,
you'll hear all sorts of terrible
language. They can do that shit.
And if by terrible you mean awesome.
I mean terrible.
If you're a fucking square.
Yeah.
There's a lot of those out
there that aren't there.
That's the other thing with the
networks and the sitcoms, a laugh track.
Nothing drives me crazier than hearing.
Even if it's a live studio audience,
it's just, I don't want to hear people
laugh. Don't tell me when the laugh,
I don't want to name the big bang
without the laugh track. No. Yeah,
there's videos on the big bang
without the laugh track and
it's fucking confusing.
Well this makes more sense.
At least you know when you listen to
people not laughing, you go, okay,
well that's much more likely.
Right?
But it also could be in their defense,
it could be like second and third
takes like the second and third take.
Like audiences don't fucking laugh.
I mean they laugh a little like ah,
but sometimes you have to do a line
like four or five times to get it right.
Or there might be a camera issue or there
might be a sound issue and they have
to repeat a scene. So when you're doing
a sitcom in front of a live audience,
there's oftentimes many takes, like we
used to fucking beat the audiences up.
Oh, it was awful. The poor people,
they would sit there and in the crowd
during the news radio days and if
something wasn't working like they
had to do it a couple of times.
Like there was times when an episode
didn't go well where it got like three,
four takes in a row. But when we would
get like first take or second take,
like we always do a second take but we
do first taking second take and they're
like we got it. I'd be like, oh my God.
Cause was third takes are brutal cause
he knew that you were wearing on people's
patients. Like the audience had
to sit there and like, oh my God,
okay we're going to do it again folks.
And you hear the audience go,
Oh oh no.
But in this video it's more just
horrible writing and horrible jokes.
It's pretty bad. But you
want to play it. Yeah,
I think we'll get pulled off of youtube,
but I think that's the theme lately.
Hot again, the big bang. These people
all just got 1 million bucks in episode.
Good for them. Good for them.
I have no, no problem with
that. I think it's amazing,
but the show sucks. It's fucking
terrible. They can't help but suck.
They're trying to suck.
They're trying to Anne and I
don't mean suck for some people.
See that's the thing about suck with
sucks for you is what other people are
looking for. And that's not
hard for people to recognize.
Like everyone wants everyone else
to have their own sensibilities.
When I say that something sucks,
someone else might come along and say,
that's my favorite shit.
Like when I was bear hunting up in Alaska,
I had a hangup or up in Canada,
I had to hang out with all these people
that love country music and they've
watched the country music channel,
the rivets, the best folks ever,
the nicest people ever. And um, they,
they play this fucking
country music shit all day.
And some of it is just mind numbing.
Just it's so,
it's just so dumb and it's,
it's not just dumb.
It's like they're appealing to like
the dumbest part of your brain,
like the part of your brain that wants
everything to be a Norman Rockwell
painting the part of your
brain that doesn't want
subtlety or nuance thinking or
it's the introduced at all the concept
that you're actually on a fucking
planet flying through the universe.
All those concepts are like,
there's none of that, you
know? Yeah. And we'll,
when we were young and wild and we got
married and had a child and all good.
Jesus is with us all the time.
Fuck you.
I just got a text. They want to make you
the newest country. Sorry. I can do it.
I can do it. Hey brought away.
How good was fucking dumb.
My rares music yesterday.
Oh, that was amazing. Dom Irrera has good
fucking music. Yeah. Dom still in music.
Dom, I rare raw, wrote a good fucking
song and I'm not bullshitting.
I'm going to get them to email
me that shit. Yeah. Here's that.
Really get them to email it to me while
a cause. I don't think he has an online.
We go,
oh,
this is the big bang.
Nothing makes beer tastes better then
cool. Rocky mountain spring water.
Well, the rocky mountains
anywhere. Philadelphia.
Really? I thought they were out west
some place. Think about it, Raj.
Where did the movie rocky take place
for the Gulf? Yeah. Okay, now I get it.
Oh, this is the plan. From now on.
We're just going to hide out
in here to avoid the shaming.
I am very comfortable here. Penny. Joe,
why don't you shoot another silver
bullet my way. I have one yourself.
Somebody who's been ticking bitchy pill.
Okay,
this is bad for America. Stop this
right here. This is bad for America.
That's not just bad. That's bad for
the world. That's bad for the country.
That's bad.
That's bad for him.
Right, and that's all riding in somebody.
Each thinking. That's funny, right?
That got through every script
supervisor and meeting and pitch.
I lighters the best of the best.
That's all the desks, ideas,
nothing on NBC and all these
guys want to really survive.
They're going to have to have like an
NBC cable or an app where NBC can make
programming that's more adult like they
do on cable or that NBC is just going to
become an APP.
When that does happen,
and it's not like cable and
network's not going to mean the same.
See,
I think you're saying that,
but I think the people that listened to
some of that dopey ass country music,
those people don't have an issue with it.
There's,
there's certain people that will tell
you, big bangs, my favorite show. Yeah,
that's a good show.
Jordy isn't like that.
That's not right.
That's why breaking bags or
HBO or showtime is getting
better ratings than anyone
did. Not. You're wrong.
You're wrong. You're wrong.
The numbers that watch breaking bad or
not nearly the numbers that watched the
big bang, it's not even close. Really?
Yeah. It's not even in the ballpark.
It's true. They only had like that, dude.
You gotta know what you're talking about.
That's not true. It is
getting, they're getting great.
They do well because they're awesome.
They're and people find them,
but they're on table.
It's way more difficult to get someone
to watch a show say on AMC or a show on,
you know, any one of those. The history
channel, it's, it's very difficult.
That's why when the duck
dynasty show got insane ratings,
they got like some crazy number, like
9 million or 7 million people to watch.
It was the highest rated cable show ever.
That's not even close to what those big
bang kids get that that's like an 18
million people a week show
they went in every week.
Sometimes the second number two of the
week is a rerun of that first show that
they're number one on. Sometimes a big
bang rerun can beat everything on TV.
What's going on is that they're trying
to trick dumb people and the thing,
and they're smart,
but watch it and nerdy show they've
made a nerdy show for dumb people.
Like they've hijacked to markets.
Yeah.
They've hijacked the people that
want to be smart and you know,
and the wanting to be nerds and then
they've also got the dumb people.
They've got both markets. It's really a
lot of dumb people. Mostly dumpy. Yeah.
Yeah. Break that breaks more ratings.
Records. Yeah, but this is a guarantee.
That's an old article because breaking
bad canceled and the duck dynasty things
post that and the duck dynasty thing
got the highest ratings ever is 2013 but
yeah, I mean the numbers,
but what's the numbers
pulled a 6.6 million,
right.
That's a fail for.
If that was,
if that was happening with the big bang,
they would be terrified.
Yeah. It's crazy what they brought and
trust me, I know what I'm talking about,
not just making this up.
I'm just saying that the,
the cable channels aren't getting great
ratings occasionally for for shows like
breaking bad. They do much better than
they used to do, but they're still,
they pale in comparison to the major
network shows. For whatever reason,
those really dumb shows still
get the best ratings. Like, yeah,
like game of Thrones is a
different example because
it's a subscription channel
and it's got far less people
tune into it like he used to be.
If you got an HBO special, that
was the shit. All my God, you know,
we saw that Sam Kinison, Hbo
Special, the Chris Rock, HBO special,
but now a comedy central special is
way better than an HBO special cause a
comedy central special is going
to be seen by way more people,
millions more people and then on top of
that they're going to replay the shit
out of it because they,
that's all they play is comedy
and people go there for comedy.
But like the numbers,
like if you look at the numbers like
you would think that like the soprano's
like well it must have been an
unbelievably high rated show.
It was for HBO but not compared to like
the big bang or compared to friends,
right.
Friends was on top or be all that stuff.
It's just amazing that those
things are still, that's,
those things are still viable and I
wonder what events always going to be the
case if there's always going
to be people who like bland,
like really easy to
swallow humor like sitcommy
humor.
I think that generation is
going to die out. I really do.
I know it's just like a fading thing and
even that thing about like the network
App, I think the people that
were re that really, really,
really are into that type of stuff though
it's going to be 10 more years before
they even know what an APP is.
Apple TV I think has going and those
kind of network TVs I think are going to
really change the thing.
Everything like the iPhone,
if they make it so that some they,
they can't get directly to
one of those three channels.
If they show them other ways,
then yeah,
but these people that watch network TV
or probably just always watch network TV,
they're used to a laugh track. They
need that. Yeah, I think so too.
I remember a part of Man on the moon
where it's a Andy Kaufman played by Jim
Carrey talking to his manager,
George Shapiro,
played by Danny Devito and he and Danny
Devito is his manager and he goes,
I got you the best Gig, Andy,
you're going to love it,
and this is in the 70s or whatever. And
Andy's like, great, what is it? He goes,
sit-com taxi. It's going to be
huge. You're going to love it.
And he goes a sitcom with a laugh track.
All those dead people laughing,
you know, those are dead
people. That's the worst stuff.
That stuff's not funny
and it's amazing to me.
You know that he was saying that at the
end of the seventies and it's still,
it's 2014 and people are still
watching stuff like that.
It's funny that you say it
because I was watching this.
I'm a hunter s Thompson
documentary the other night.
I just put it on while I was
cleaning my office. And um, it's,
it's from the BBC. The BBC did a, um, uh,
a piece on him and um, oh, I'll
tell you what it is right here.
Oh, actually I don't have it on this. Um,
anyway,
it was,
it was very pocalypse pick like his take
on society and America where America is
headed. And this is in the early
seventies. They did this thing,
maybe the late seventies at the,
at the very latest wasn't the 80s though.
You know, you're, you're watching
this guy who's now committed suicide.
He's dead brilliant writer.
Who's seeing the shift from the 60s to
the 70s and he's saying that America is
just going downhill.
We become this fascist,
ridiculous state and our, our,
our culture is eroding and that,
you know, within, you know, 10, 20
years it's going to be over for us.
And now here we are, 2014, you know,
30 plus years later and everybody's still
kind of saying the same shit. You know,
everybody's still kind of
saying, you know, hey, it's
all, it's all falling apart.
Hey Arc, I'll culturals disastrous.
It's, it's doom and gloom always.
I think that what's going
on is that there's always
going to be a certain amount.
What does this fear and loathing and
on the road to Hollywood's at the BBC
documentary. Yeah. Okay. Um,
I think there's always going
to be a certain amount of, uh,
of people that think that the
world is ending. Sky's falling,
and there's going to be
a certain of bullshit
that goes on always.
There's always going to be people trying
to correct for all the evils of the
world,
whether it's war or crime or this or that.
There's always going to be that and
then there's always going to be like an
adjustment period where you know you have
like a bunch of police brutality cases
and then someone figures out a way to a
stop the police from behaving that way
and then you know,
things get better or is it going to be
like horrible war and then people protest
the horrible war and then it gets better.
It's just,
it seems like these ideas that it's all
gonna fall apart and society is going to
collapse.
Like I think all that shit happened,
the society collapsing back when people
didn't understand the society could
collapse and now we have so much detailed
history on like what it takes for a
society to become like
Rome when Rome fell,
what it takes for a society to become,
you know,
like one of these archetypal societies
that people talk about when the,
you know, the ancient Greeks
or the Romans or any of these.
When you talk about like a society that
was on top of everything had all of
these scholars and all these
intelligent people and then collapsed.
Yeah.
It's going to be interesting to see what
the next big one like that is because
it's going to have technology and robots
and a whole bunch of crazy stuff like
way down the road,
but there's going to be some crazy stuff
you saw him far away. Yeah. I
think the technology, robots,
all that shit like we're where things
are going to be so much weirder than the
art. Today's going to
happen so fast. You know?
If you listen to like Ray
Kurzweil and these futurists guys,
their take on it is always so enlightening
because everybody wants to think of
it as like,
you know,
when we were kids we had
VCRs and now we have Netflix.
What a jump,
what a leap.
But the leap really has been
within the past few years,
the past few years has been bigger
leaps and they were from the VCR to the
Internet.
Like did the delete you getting crazier?
There's a fucking app that they came out
with for Google face or Google a Google
glasses that recognizes
your moods. Whoa. Yeah.
What it recognizes your fucking mood.
Like, if I come up to you with this,
Google, Google, I can't
even say Google glass.
I'm just gonna call it Google glass.
If I come up to you with this app
installed and wearing Google glasses,
it tells me if you're happy. It
tells me if you're angry, let's,
it analyzes your face. Interesting.
That's creepy as shit man.
Pull that up.
Pull it up.
Lot of cameras have something like
that already built in with the smile
detection.
Like where are you pointing a camera and
it will take a picture when it detects
that you're smiling. Oh, okay.
But that's not breeding like mood.
It's just detecting a certain
movement of your face.
This fucking stupid thing is actually
trying to like look at someone's face and
decide,
you know that gross thing that really
cheesy dude's due to chicks or they go,
hey,
it doesn't hurt to smile.
You know it actually a more muscles are
involved in frowning here and smiling.
It takes more energy to frown.
Does a smile,
hey, you know why not smile? You
know that thing, that gross thing,
that dude's due to checks.
Have you ever seen a guy do that makes
you fucking embarrassed to be a man? Yeah.
That's going to be way more commonplace.
People are going to be doing that
all the time. My Google glass is,
recognizes you're not in the best mood
right now. He, uh, my Google glass,
it says you're depressed. Do you
need a hug? Cause I'm here. You know,
just take a chance. I'm a
good guy. Did, uh, did, uh,
you were wearing Google glasses
or are you just happy to see me?
It's totally wrong.
You got it the wrong way.
What is this?
A video that Google glass on Google
glass did take the information behind.
See this for the first time.
We'll give the zooming up.
Don't frown.
Hoofers proprietary
shore software library.
Let's have a look at how it works.
Sure.
Process is high resolution video
in real time on the glass CPU.
Does it only work on nerdy checks,
emotions or do detection?
Oh my God.
In addition to that,
it does age and gender recognition and
age estimation and gender recognition.
What if you're a like a really
good looking older transsexual man,
you think it'll get you
at the time of this Beta.
This has only worked on white people.
That is a beautiful old man.
Sure is not limited to a single phase,
uh, angry hipster or respect
other people's privacy.
There is no recognition of milestones
and none of the images leaves the device.
Fuck you. It doesn't, but that's
not all our short technology can do.
Even more helpful things not
shown in this demonstration.
Valance recognition for
very subtle reactions. Whoa.
Head pose estimation. I blinked
detection. This was just a demo.
Okay. This one corner is not
available in an APP store.
This looks like a pirate and his hostage.
It's not available in an APP store.
What does that mean? It's now maybe now
available. Not Ready yet. Not Ready. Oh,
it might be bullshit.
And that might've been just like a,
like we might've gotten fucking pranked.
You know,
it says it's not available to an
APP store cause it seems so fake.
If I saw that years ago,
I would say that's total bullshit
because that technology was so good.
Alien I the idea of it.
But now after the Google glass thing,
you might not be able to
tell by the smile on my face,
but I'd be really disappointed
if that's not real.
That's the thing is like it can't really,
it's just seeing if your mouth moves
side to side and like it's frowning,
but some people,
you know,
some people cry happy tears and some
people smile when they're furious.
Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
He's super happy joking with this guy.
You're looking at Ted Bundys car,
nice car
that's been barred.
It's full.
A happy good cheekbones guys smiling.
Got a clown mask door. Doesn't
have an inside handle. Yeah.
Oh he's got a knife in his tank.
I'm sure that's for cutting birthday cake.
He's a happy guy.
Duct tape.
Weird.
But one day they're going to get really
good at it to the point where there will
be able to detect.
It's going to really be able to
show you gonna be able to detect,
not just that you're going to be
able to detect people's thoughts,
like it's going to start out with moods,
but eventually you're going to be able
to see like graphic representations and
what a person's thinking.
You'll be able to tune that.
They'll be able to figure out. I think
the way they're going to have to do it is,
I've been thinking about
this a lot. You know how, um,
there was no cameras and then they
became cameras. Like when we were young,
there was no way that you could ever
imagine that someone was going to carry
around a camera all the time like that.
You wouldn't think of that.
You saw a camera,
it was around someone's waist or someone's
neck router and they'd have to hold
it up and take that picture.
It wasn't just simply like this
little phone thing that were going on.
Now that's a big leap.
The,
the big leap of having cameras
in your pocket at all times.
Um, and if you went back before
the invention of the camera,
if you went way, way
back to like, you know,
back in the days when there was just
paintings and drawings and things along
those lines,
they could have never imagined that
you'd be able to make video from a little
tiny slender device that
you stick in your pocket.
You read the devil if you showed them
that and now this phone that you can take
video with and go online with and take
photographs now it's become a part of you.
It's become a part of who you are.
It's like it's a symbiotic thing.
You keep it with you.
You'd never leave the house without it.
When you do you freak out.
I think they're going to come up with
something that stores your memory better
than you do.
Are they going to say we have in,
it'll probably be like an addition,
like an upgrade to the human
memory banks. I come here, we have,
yeah,
like a memory card.
But that did shows you crystal
clear video of what you saw.
So like, you know how if you had to pull
like yesterday out of your memory banks,
he'd be like, ah, fuck, what
did I do? What did I do? What
did I do? Okay, I got up, I,
this is what I had for breakfast. But
it's all blurry as fuck. Right, right.
They're going to be able to get
it so that it's exact, well,
you'll be able to rewind and play it back
Google glasses,
what did I do yesterday at 1245 right.
And then you're gonna be able to
share that with other people. Yeah.
You're going to be able to share your day.
What I'm wondering is,
is if it'll ever to the point to where
we're paying for our privacy.
You know,
like once everything's all
wired in and you had the,
you know,
once your Google glasses or in a cloud
with what you looked up on the Internet
that day and you're walking by somebody
with Google glasses and you know what I
mean?
Like they walk by and it's like,
you know a bubble pops up over their head
and you know this guy was looking at,
you know yeah double
anal clown porn earlier.
It's like whoa that's stranger was
looking at clown porn. That's crazy.
But like if they paid $10 a month or
something that other people wouldn't be
able to know what they know.
Like I'm wondering how fast and
how far it's really going to go.
Cause I think about it a lot too.
Cause I love pot and I think there's
something about pot that makes you love
thinking about the future.
Especially technology cause
I mean it's all happening.
It's so weird and privacy and phone
calls and things backed up can know
everything. You can find out
everything about somebody,
their daily habits every time.
Gina's thing about the cell phone towers
that they don't believe or really cell
phone towers,
their cell phone,
their cell phone towers that they've
located that don't seem to be transmitting
cell phone data and they've
gone to them with like these,
these devices that try to read and what
they think is going on is the cell phone
towers are actually tapping into phone
calls and recording your information.
Like say if the police want to find out
where Tony Hinchcliffe is right now and
you know you could use the gps on the
phone and find out that he's on the four
oh five and he's headed
to San Diego and you know,
and then they go,
okay,
we're going to tap into his phone so
they can tune in through that tower and
listened to your phone calls. You're
like, I got the fucking heroin.
The dude's off duct taped in the trunk.
I've got 15 different
handguns that are all illegal.
Everyone's laughing on
the other end. We, you,
the cops are listening to the entire
conversation. Like they can do that. Yeah.
There was a terror I that just went
up in my backyard the other day,
like out of nowhere,
there was no construction out of nowhere.
Tia. Yeah, black helicopters. They've
been doing this Brian for a long time.
That was
fun getting to meet him and it has two
antennas on the top like that looked like
wifi antennas.
You can't see him in this picture.
But then there's a solar panel and
we have our uh, overhead lines,
power lines in our neighborhood.
So there's like, you know,
they're above ground and
there's no power going to it.
So that means this is whatever this is
is just running on a solar and it has
antennas and like a weird
box on the side of it.
It's probably nothing.
Yeah,
probably like what you mean
you're freaking out about it.
Why don't you just find out what it
is? Yeah, I bet it has a number on it.
You can call or something. No, it doesn't.
For reading problems. Go here. Did you
try to research what it is now? I mean,
why don't you take a photo of
it and put it up on Twitter?
Take that picture and what they say.
What did people say?
People are pointing towards this,
that article.
That's the only thing that
people have been saying.
Yeah, but see, people do
that when they, you know,
if you don't really know what the fuck
it is. I might be that though. Yeah. Who?
I didn't,
I'm not even
saying it to that.
I'm just saying it was really odd because
one day it was there, one day will,
it wasn't and it was just like
in my neighbor's backyard.
I wonder if they can do that.
Can you take a cell phone tower and
attach it to an electrical pole or does it
have to have it's own stand alone
sort of thing? I would think that,
I don't know anything about it,
but I would think that the
s the electricity would
maybe fuck with it all that,
all that power going through those lines.
If they don't let us turn on,
if they make us turn off our cell phones
when the plane's about to take off,
I don't think they could put a cell
phone tower on it. Yeah, but that's a,
that's a stupid thing. That whole
turn off your electronic devices.
That's all been disproven now.
So that's why everybody's allowed to use
like iPods and shit and iPads right up
until the time you land. But you're
still not allowed to use Bluetooth.
Like if you have those Bluetooth headsets,
like there was a dude in front of
me on the airplane the other day.
He had the Bluetooth headset and a,
they told him he couldn't have it on.
You couldn't have it on while the
plane because it could interfere with
communications. Yeah, but
that's probably bullshit too.
So they probably just don't know any
better and they just say it because they
just want to tell you to shut something
off and they can't do that anymore.
I think it's awesome for planning things.
So you can't have like a
Bluetooth headpiece and you're
sitting in the front row
and I'm in the back row and we're all
kind of communicating like, hey, you know,
like terrorist stuff. Awesome. Do
they work like that? I don't know.
That seems like that wouldn't you if you
had to communicate with somebody else
in the plane? Yeah, but a Bluetooth
headset, as far as I'm aware,
all it does is communicate with
an actual device. Like a phone.
You'd have to be talking on the phone to
someone in the back of the plane. Yeah.
I don't think you can communicate
through Bluetooth, can you? Yeah.
I mean you can connect Bluetooth,
that Bluetooth and stuff like that,
but can you connect Bluetooth too?
Bluetooth and talk like if you had,
I don't think so, man. I think you need
some sort of a transmission device.
I think like if you had a Bluetooth head
set on it and I had a Bluetooth headset
on, we couldn't just connect our
headsets and communicate with each other.
We would have to do it through a device.
Right. I don't know how that Bluetooth,
Jamie, I've never had one. I'm no, no
either. Well, even if you couldn't,
you'd probably will be able to write and
within a year or so they'll figure it
out. It's all happening so God damn fast.
Oh yeah. There's, it looks like, yeah,
there's Bluetooth headset, walkie talkies
on Amazon. Oh, it's a walkie talkie.
And it's like just in a little
earpiece in your ear. That's it.
That's the whole device. Whoa. Whoa.
That's what, that's scary. Check this out.
Uh Oh shit. I gotta get your video up.
Uh, like a heavy small
wireless and visible earpiece.
G A Bluetooth earpiece. Wow.
That looks like an actual tooth.
Well that's when someone can talk to
you through a walkie talkie though.
I use those when I was on fear factor,
they've had those forever.
They used to use radios and now now
they use Bluetooth. But all that is,
is allowing you to talk. You have to
have a walkie talkie on you, on you.
And it connects to the walkie talkie.
Mine used to connect with
a radio frequency. I'd
wear like a backpack,
like a battery pack rather.
The slow communication pack
and it would work that way.
But someone else on the other end
had to have a communication device.
They had a walkie talkie and they were
talking through that and it would go to
directly to me and I couldn't talk to
them except for the fact that I was
hardwired with a microphone that also
had a radio frequency that went to a box.
And the box,
there was a guy,
there was a sound guy that was there
and it would go through them and through
their, uh, through their speakers.
But it was like the entire
cast was wired up, so all,
and you could turn each
microphone on or off,
but that requires a lot of equipment.
You know,
you've got a lot of different
shit going on there.
What I'm saying is if someone has a
Bluetooth headset on just a Bluetooth
headset,
if they don't have a phone that's on,
you're not talking to somebody and you
can't really talk to somebody on a phone
when you're on an airplane.
Here's a, here's the one. It
looks like you can do it. It's a,
it looks like a walkie talkie thing and
it says that it has a two way walkie
talkie. Whoa. For 84,000 feet. Whoa. Oh,
so they're basically saying
that's what it does. Yeah.
Who makes that one tooth call?
pod.com onyx looks like call pod.
The onyx is the name of that. I'm just
saying that, but that is a walkie talkie.
Yeah. That might be something that
it already does exist. Wow. Yeah.
That's crazy. It's insane
because Bluetooth already
makes people look crazy. What?
Yeah, would they have radios? Yeah.
Yeah. These are walkie talkies.
What we're saying is that this little
thing that that person had in their ear,
that that itself is a walkie talkie.
That's fucking nuts.
That's that little one to how far that
transmits though, because Bluetooth,
the Bluetooth, you can't really
communicate very far. Eight 84,000 feet.
That's in the air. They're saying,
does that mean distance? No,
they don't mean in the air. Planes
don't get that high. That's space.
That's like three times what a plane goes
as the square feet square feet 84,000
oh, so, okay, so it transmits 84,000 feet.
30,000 feet is a flight,
so 84,000 feet is like more than a mile.
How many thousand feet is a mile?
Five thousand five thousand feet in a
mile, right. Damn. That's pretty insane.
So you could be like essentially down
at Jerry's Deli having a meal and I can
talk to you in real time through
these goofy ass. We should buy these.
That's so crazy. What is the
company name again? Call pod. Uh,
that's where I think that's I,
that's where it's sold. It's Onyx.
O. N Y. X. Oh,
N y. X. Hmm.
So it's like walkie talkies,
except you keep one in your ear,
but how does it pick
up what you're saying?
You just can roam up to 164 feet away.
That's not that far.
When what happened?
I thought we was miles from
your smartphone. That's for,
so it has to have a smart phone. No, no.
That's just phrase it as,
that's just for smartphones.
If you want to use it as a headset
for your smart phone. Yeah.
This is what it says with our proprietary
two way walkie talkie functionality.
You can also connect the
onyx to any other call Pod,
Bluetooth headset and communicate up to
84,000 square feet while you were still
connected to your mobile phone. Oh, you
have to be connected to your mobile phone.
Hmm. I don't know. I'm not
sure. You can use Bluetooth.
Yeah,
I'm not sure what this is saying that
you can connect to any other call Pod,
Bluetooth headset and communicate up to
84,000 square feet while you are still
connected to your mobile phone.
It's just saying that you could still
use it and do the walkie talkie at the
same time. Like if you're
still connected to your phone,
you could still use it as the walk.
Right? Like you don't have
to disconnect. We, yeah,
we got to find out if this really works.
All right. We're going to have to buy,
these pitchers will buy them and
we'll, we'll broadcast like you.
Can we do that?
I wonder if we could get it so that
we could put the earpiece up to the
microphone and you could go out in the
parking lot and talk to us. Oh yeah.
Put it like right up there and
see if it works. Yeah, absolutely.
Over you have to say over though.
Red Band over we got,
we got smoking in the Bush over,
but it was all excited because they
have those fucking those stupid walkie
talkie phones. Those are the dumbest
ever it goes to next tell those.
But everybody wanted them. They wanted
to be like fucking walkie talkie guy.
When we were in high school,
we didn't have cell phones in our phones,
so we all had a CB radios in our car
and we all had the humongous antennas on
the topic of car.
Oh yeah.
But it was cool because we all live
within a couple miles of each other so we
can just like use it as a cell phone
before there were cell phones and just to
be driving around in our car being like,
where are you at? Where you want to go?
Smoke some weed at the
church. Sure. You know? Wow.
You're probably all on police
frequencies. Yeah, totally. Totally. Yeah.
We got the, I think two kids are
about to go smoke weed at a church.
Yup. Yeah. How about
those police scanners?
You ever go over someone's house and they
got a police scanner going on all the
time? I got one on my phone. I
listen to it all the time. Yeah.
But I mean like those real ones that
people have in their home. Right.
Those are weird.
Just the domestic violence network.
We have another beating.
Yeah.
Which just something weird about people
that want to constantly be in tune with
all the crime that's going on around them.
Yeah.
It's probably guys that like wanting to
be in the police force but couldn't pass
the examinations. Oh Man. What's
that fire truck going by far?
The figures,
they know all these assholes in
my neighborhood are up to no good.
I just saw an ambulance and I
need to know what's going on now.
I do it sometimes like lists.
I think it's interesting.
Yeah. I mean, I guess so. Yeah. I mean
look, voyeurism like and you know,
being able to rubberneck
right. Uh, crimes and stuff.
One of the things they're saying
is they're going to try to,
in La they're going to try to raise
up the walls in between the two lanes,
the north and the southbound lanes.
She people rubber neck so much and it
causes so much traffic. Oh, it's insane.
Yeah.
It's,
it's really frustrating when you get
somewhere and you realize that the only
reason why everyone drove slows cause
some shit went on the other side of the
fucking highway,
like you fucking self
for Chicago in the middle of the
highway then it should not slow us down.
But everybody wants to see everybody
should just get CB radios and keep driving
at 75 miles an hour.
Yeah.
I don't think that's going to help.
I know the only thing that's gonna help
ally as if it was like multiple layers.
Like we would need like
several layers of highways.
Like you could drive up to the upper
highway if you really weren't scared of
earthquakes. Yeah. Or if
you wanted to be on the top.
So if the earthquake happened,
you ride that bitch down at the
bottom and crush everybody below you.
Yeah. You know in Silicon Valley where
that one dude had a really skinny car,
wears like a one person car.
He almost looked like a set piece of sand.
Like a bread. I don't know what you're
talking about. Yes, I saw it. Yeah.
It's like a,
imagine if a car like a mini Cooper was
cut in half and make it himself now.
It was just kind of a joke. Like that
guy is so rich and look at his car,
how skinny it is. He's like, he's like
poverty bud. Want to listen to your idea?
I'm Outta here.
And he gets in this tiny,
cause it's silicone valley and it's all
just you talking about the TV show. Yeah.
Oh Jesus Christ. Sorry. Yeah. But yeah,
but what if we all had just one person
cars in the future? Whereas cars,
motorcycles get to go in between cars.
So what if we just had to like really
skinny cars? Yeah. That's a death trap.
Yeah.
That's not good.
That doesn't even a lot of room for
error if somebody hits you. Yeah.
That's the thing that
everybody's looking at. Like,
like when when you see a Volvo
guaranteed there's a pussy in that car.
Someone in there. I was like
terrified of crashes. That's just,
that's just how it is with Volvos.
Got a six star safety rating and
I just can't get hit out here.
Well Joey Diaz drives a Volvo did the
best fucking car you've ever going to have
like the Volvo too. So there it
goes. My theory, my theory sucks,
but so many of those people
that do drive those things,
so like super safety conscious because of,
that's one of the things that all
their commercials were geared to. Yeah.
This is a boring ass car.
Yeah, yeah. Yes. Not Fast,
but look what happens when you
throw it off a cliff. Boom.
Nothing like they build those things
to like withstand nuclear blasts.
Like you know,
if you got one of those,
you're not going to eat that
shit in for a fucking motorcycle.
Super Safe. They only go 45
miles an hour. But it's so sad.
Well they go normal speeds now.
They're pretty fast cars.
I mean there's not much difference
when you get to like the high end cars.
I mean there's,
there's a difference as far as like one
of them handles more comfortably but
they're modern cars are so god damn good.
There's so much better.
Like that car that we had
in Denver that a Hellcat,
that's a 707 horsepower American car,
ridiculous car.
That was unheard 20
years ago.
I did literally,
I literally grew chest hair
while sitting in that thing.
Like some people use that as a figure of
speech. Like, oh put hair on my chest.
Like I looked at in the hotel room when
I was showering after that and I had
more chest hair.
It's three times the car I've ever been in
that sound.
But the point is like that didn't exist.
It wasn't even possible.
Like when you've got a really fast car
from 1970 and I had like 400 horsepower
and it was just a death trap. Terrible
breaks. No handling. It was like a,
an elephant on roller skates.
I mean that's what it was like just about
every way you was plowing into shit.
Barely able to stop.
The cars today are just infinitely better.
So if you took a Volvo of today,
which you consider like a super safe car,
very boring, and took it around a race
track with like a 1970 challenger,
it would bury that car and we just fucking
run circles around it and breaking,
handling everything. And
he'd be like, Whoa Volvos,
the greatest fucking hot rod ever.
No it's just old cars sucked
a fat one old cars, you just,
they're just clunky ass shitty technology.
That Hellcat challenger.
It's 700 horsepower,
700 that means that like the equivalent
of that back in the day would be a
carriage being pulled by 700 horses and
just the one guy in this care in the
pack it says hello.
But not even that because if you did
have a carriage pulled by 700 horses and
right next to it you had a challenge
or the challenge of the fucking blow by
that cause it would
gone. It wouldn't even
be close. It, I mean,
wouldn't let the race would last as much
time as it takes for the challenge to
drive past the horses. That's it. Once
it got to the 700 horse, it's gone.
Yeah. I Dunno. Understand horsepower
cause some horses are bigger too. Yeah.
Some horses. Anything to do with
horses really. I think originally,
well let's find out.
Like I'd imagine a horse is
one horsepower, right? Yeah.
But like some horses win the Kentucky
Derby and other ones fall in or fat stupid
faces.
Surprised they don't have that for
other things. Like how a bicycle,
how many cat power is that?
Well, I was thinking, man, that's the
other place that we got to do a podcast.
We got to do a podcast
from the Kentucky Derby in,
in reference to a hunters Thompson is
one of his greatest books that awards
greatest pieces was the Kentucky
Derby is decadent and depraved.
It's fucking great.
Great piece.
Where it's like you went to the
Kentucky Derby and then, you know,
like was essentially there were
mocking all the people that were there.
You know, he was, uh, categorizing all
the monsters that were there, but the,
by the end of the piece, he realized
he was one of them. You know,
they're all fucked up and they're at
the Kentucky Derby. They realize like,
we're no better than any of these savages
that are here. Measurements of power,
horsepower. It's a unit of measurement
of power. The rate of which work is done.
The most common conversion factor,
especially for electrical
power is one equals 746 watts.
The term was adopted in the late 18th
century by Scottish engineer James Watt to
compare the output of steam engines
with the power of draft horses. Huh.
It was later expanded to include the
output power of other types of piston
engines as well as turbines,
electric motors and other machinery.
The definition of the unit varied
between geographical regions.
Hmm.
That's interesting.
Most countries now use the s I unit watt
for the measurement of power with the
implementation of the EU directive.
Bubba Bubba, blah, blah, blah. Huh.
That's interesting. In the, in
the EU, the European Union, uh,
the use of horsepower is only
permitted as a supplementary unit.
Like when you look at cars, um, you know,
like if you look at an American
car for 700 horsepower,
well 700 horses under the truck
or under the, under the hood.
If you look at European cars,
like on European a websites,
they have it listed as like,
like watts and kilowatts of power.
It's really kind of
weird like a Land Rover,
here's perfect one because
it's an English company.
Okay.
If you go to their, uh, their, uh,
okay.
They're a website and you
read what they have. It's a,
it's really kind of interesting.
Like you,
you try to make sense of like what is
a watt, how much is in that, you know,
like what does like a land rover defenders
like their version of like a jeep,
like dimensions and capabilities,
engine and performance here.
Yeah. Engine speed. At maximum torque.
They have torque Newton meters.
Like it doesn't say horsepower.
The power and kilowatts,
kilowatts kw slash p s I thought kilowatts
was just a back to the future thing.
I know that's chicken box that
senescence Vanessa say it didn't
Land Rover defender,
which is like their version of the
jeep has a 90 kilowatt one 22 p s uh,
power rating.
So that's how they do in England.
Hmm.
They hate America. Yeah.
That's what's going on.
She didn't know horsepower sounds
better. You Silly Brits. Yeah,
because whenever you like read
about a Ferrari or a Porsche,
it's always in horsepower, right?
Silly Fox. Yeah, the European Union.
What,
what we go by the watt system.
But it is a smarter way to do it.
Really kilowatts. Colas. It is.
Why do you think we do it that way too?
I mean it makes sense.
What the fuck is a horse doing?
Being measuring cards.
So American, it's so good.
How many power or horses is,
yeah, we're going to be as fuck. We really
are. We're so goofy with inches too.
Like when I was a kid,
they legitimately tried to introduce the
metric system to schools and I remember
pm people being like, fuck off,
throwing their rollers at the teacher.
They were just not buy it. Man.
That was in my lifetime. I saw it,
they were trying to introduce the metric
system just like they were trying to
introduce soccer. I was like very similar.
It was like, and people were like, Nah,
no, not having it. The metric
system though is so much better.
It's everything is intense.
It makes sense when we do fights
and other countries in England,
England is the weirdest
cause they still go by stone.
Do you know what a stone is? What? Yeah.
If you were being measured
to be stands 11 stone.
Yeah. How much is astounding? I Dunno.
Why would they do stones
and not horsepower?
I mean horses are pretty much
are a lot closer than Stellan.
Sometimes there's a huge stone.
I think a stone is like 14
pounds or 13 pounds. Dude,
I'm only like six stones.
Okay.
In many north western European countries,
the stone was formerly used for trade
with a value ranging from about five to 40
local pounds.
With the advent of metrication
from the mid 19th century on,
it was superseded by the kilogram and
remained in limited use for trade in the
United Kingdom and in Ireland
until prohibited by the weights.
And measures act of 1985 but okay.
Yeah,
it's 14 pounds.
But they still use it for like weighing
in fighters when fighters way in this
Bruce Beth say that? Yes. Oh yeah. Well he
doesn't say it. He doesn't really say it.
I actually say it. The guy says it
to me, the guy, I'll say it to me,
you know 14 stone, but when Bruce Buffer.
Oh, okay. That's right. That's string way.
Bruce buffer does say it though.
When they not sure if he still
does, if there's an actual, um,
during the actual like fight announcement,
but at the way in,
I would have to say it. Wow. I would
have to say like one stone, 10 pounds,
you know, one 55, you
know, x amount of stones.
What does that 10 stone like?
Not quite 11 stone.
This fucking so strange.
10 stone,
nine pounds. And he'd say shit like
that. Wow. That is a weird unit.
They stopped doing that
after a while though.
And they had me just read off the weights.
Like I don't,
I don't read the kilos anymore either.
Like if someone says one 55 it's
one 55 like it's, this is like,
it's too confusing for American fans.
86 kilos shit. Can we get to a computer?
You should start guessing.
The fighters horsepower announcing
that weighing in at six stone and 140
horsepower. You know what's interesting
is that it, that's kind of silly,
but it's true in fact that the
guys with the more horsepower,
they run out of gas quicker because it's
very relative. Yeah, they like muscle.
The plants,
how to get there,
like there's a certain
amount of horsepower you
need and then after that it's
kind of ridiculous.
It's like you're seeing with a race car,
like if you have a car and it's a gt car,
like if you're going around like a,
like a Nurburg ring or something
like that, like a real windy course,
a lot of handling.
You don't necessarily want like a
thousand horsepower engine in your car.
You want as much engine as
your suspension can handle.
And when it comes to like miles
per hour and miles per gallon,
you want like a balance between the two.
You want to,
we want an engine that produces plenty
of horsepower but not so much horsepower
that it burns up all your fuel in 30
minutes and you lose the race because
everybody keeps going and you're done.
You're out of gas.
That's true with the body to like,
can you see like some dude,
he's got this giant fucking massive
muscles. The reality is that shit is a,
that's like a giant engine and a small
gas tank and there's no other way around
it.
That's how the human body is.
There's a balancing act going on so that
guy could get you if he get you quick,
but if the shit gets
dragged into the third,
fourth and fifth rounds
I got might be toast.
He might have a goddamn
heart attack in there.
Do you ever find out what happened
to that guy's ribs from Saturday?
That Pot's guy up?
Is that like 17 punches in the rich?
Way More than that. Oh my
God. It was [inaudible] 67
then unanswered body shots. That's
what it was. Yeah. Oh my God.
Through all through bolt.
Two or three rounds,
whatever many rounds it was
the fight where it was stopped.
He kept covering his head but he left
his body open and I remember the guy just
kept hitting that same spot.
It was crazy.
Was very sloppy. Yeah. That was
not a good fight. I just, you know,
it's unfortunate but true
that the larger guys,
like a lot of the larger guys
like the skill level is just not,
does not compare and it's not because
like they're not capable of moving.
Right.
Cause like look at the way a guy like,
like a super athlete moves,
you know,
look at away like peanut pick,
pick your favorite basketball player.
Lebron James is probably the biggest
super athlete in the world. Right.
Look at the way that guy moves now.
If that guy was an MMA fighter,
do you think you would move like
those guys? No. He'd move like he is,
he has a super athlete. Those guys
like especially pots, it's just like,
it was real stiff and awkward. It was
just shitty technique. That's just not,
that's not indicative of what you
would expect from a high level athlete.
I think that was like the
real problem with that fight.
It's just the other dude's good.
Yeah.
Well the way that it would do you know,
the way that it finished was what blew my
mind. Yeah. I mean just watching a man,
a heavyweight take heavyweight shots to
the ribs and especially the same spot.
I was noticing when the guy's hand
would pick up and he'd wind up,
he would hit in that exact same little
square diameter that his fist was before
and I have all the stuff.
I've seen a live,
I don't think I've seen anything like that
just because the guy did
a shit job of defending,
but Anthony Hamilton's a good fighter.
He's a very good fighter,
but it was his first fight.
It was his first UFC bout.
He moved so much better.
Like you could see the he moved like is
just the way he is able to physically
move back and forth.
That's a big thing with heavyweights.
Just how much athleticism did they have?
I mean how much of it is just sheer size
and bulk and horsepower and how much of
it is athleticism?
Yeah.
I've been watching it
some pro wrestling.
He totally predicted what was
going to happen with this.
John seen a Brock Lesnar,
you knew the thing white out about it.
Brock Lesnar,
you played it out long
at advance perfectly.
He knew exactly how it
was going to go down.
And you're saying that it's
sets up something in the future?
Oh yeah, absolutely. They offered
me a full time writing job.
I can talk about it now cause I'm
not getting it. I'm not doing it.
But a couple months ago they offered
me a full time job to move to Stamford,
Connecticut. Yeah. After one
meeting at a meeting like this,
that was about an hour and a half.
At the end they go,
how would you feel about moving to
Stamford Connecticut for one year job with
the WWE writing hung the
creative side and I go,
I'm going to have to think about that.
And it didn't pan out because I
didn't want to move to Stanford,
Connecticut and working nine to five.
Even those really good
money and everything, but
you would have to go to,
you drive to a la or drive to New
York rather still do spots. Yeah.
Which turns out it's
just a 45 minute drive,
but the job is very grueling
than WWE thing. It's not,
it's not like our TV comedy writing job.
It's like a,
I'd have to answer to Vince Mcmahon
like Tony. Oh, what'd you do?
Get stoned before writing this ideal.
Do you think that's what it was? Sorry.
Probably. What would you say to him? Well,
if you want to say, yeah, I was still,
when I wrote all the great ideas that
you like, sir. Well, you have a point.
I think Vince would try to
get you on steroids. Um,
he'd probably get me
tried to get me to eat
beef every chance he gets brought
in and price in this from my ranch.
I shot this myself this morning.
Yeah. Well was it good money? Like
serious money. Super serious money. Wow.
Sanely serious money. You came
close. I was happy to get the offer.
I took it as a victory
and I love what I do.
I love what I'm doing and it might
be crazy. I'll never regret it.
You know what I mean? I think you regret
it right now. I'm looking into your eyes,
so no, no. It's kind of a dream job
for you. Yeah, sort of. But then again,
what I do is sort of a dream job too,
and giving up this dream job for
that dream job would be crazy.
You wouldn't have to give
up this dream job. Right.
I'm telling you it's a grueling,
creepy job. Unfortunately.
Trust me, if it was, if,
if the word on the streets was man
riding for the WWE is the coolest,
you can do anything.
I would have taken it and I would have
lived in New York and it would have been
amazing.
I would have traveled to Stanford 45
minutes every morning on a subway and
Dunnigan Stanford. He, yeah, it would have
been amazing and I would have had any,
I could've, it was stupid. The amount of
money. You don't want to live in Stanford.
You know what the problem with
Connecticut is? It's not really a state.
It is a state, but let's be
honest, ladies and gentlemen,
you, you live in a highway but she in
Boston? In New York. Yeah, absolutely.
It's like they put some houses on the
side of the highway and they call it a
town, but that's what's really
going on. There's nothing,
nothing's being done there and nuns
to be made there. What do you got?
You got the Glenn Beck show and the WWE.
That's your entire state economy.
Of course. There's some other things
I'm just fucking around. Don't get,
don't get all fucking all stanfordy on me.
Don't get like all attached and proud
of Connecticut, Connecticut pride.
We've got a fucking email, Joe
Connecticut pride. Connecticut sucks.
You know it sucks and I know it sucks.
There's some great houses there.
Some nice neighborhoods, crazy
neighbor. I have my friend Tommy Junior,
one of my best friends lives
in Connecticut. He tells
me it sucks. I trust him.
It's not a good spot. When I used to
drive there from Boston to New York,
I would always think like, why is, why
are people stopping here? Yeah, WWE.
But a lot of people like,
you know,
David Letterman lived in Connecticut
and drove into the city to do a show.
That's how he did it. Yeah. But he's
like reclusive, you know, he likes being,
he needs to be away from everybody.
He's weird like that. And you're not.
You missed her outgoing and that
city partying it up at night,
doing a little blow in the morning,
pep you up right before class for sure.
You know me show up on the campus.
Give Vince the paperwork that you
wrote on the plane over there. Tony,
this storyline makes zero sense.
What kind of storylines where you
plan it? Did you, I know you did.
I know you thought about it.
Absolutely.
Absolutely. I wrote a, I wrote a
great storyline where, you know,
Brock Lesnar and a,
in this past Wrestlemania,
he beat the undertaker. The undertaker's
had a streak at Wrestlemania.
He never loses at Wrestlemania.
He was 21 and zero all time
at Wrestlemania 21 years.
He had never lost in this match
against Brock Lesnar. It's Sorta,
it was sort of set up so everybody just
assumed the undertaker would win and
then in a stunning move,
Brock,
towards the end of it ends up beating
the undertaker for the three count.
You want to see something funny? Look
that up. Reaction shots of the audience.
Don't do that. Okay, but this audience
was stunned to people. Just so I know.
What else? Shots drawn that audience. A
fucking simple card trick. Oh, come on.
What are you talking about?
Code road.
Silly Shit. Okay. It's all
planned out. It's obvious.
It's not obvious. It's definitely not.
If it's planned out, why would it be?
It was going to happen. I know what's
going to happen. No, that's not the,
that's not the arena's. Not everybody
in the arena was offered a full time,
one year writing job with the,
they don't know what's going to happen.
You're an expert and pro wrestling
essentially. I've watched my whole,
it was sort of like my replacement for
not having a dad when I was a kid. Like,
I would just sit there and watch these,
these storylines and these guys
do all this crazy stuff and said,
well sure it was my dad replaced
superfly snuck. Oh, was
your dad pretty much?
Super Fly was one of the biggest things.
I mean that's what I was doing off of
couches and my tidy whities when I was a
tiny little boy, Bob Backlund.
I remember Bob Backlund,
the creator of the cross face chicken
wing, which is a great move man.
Fucking time you invest in this.
You should get paid by this.
Seriously considered seriously
consider taking that job? Uh, no.
I would say no to anybody else, but
you, you liked that shit so much.
You've always got those fucking books.
He reads books on the
business of pro wrestling.
We're on a fucking plane and I look over,
there's people reading self help books.
Some folks are reading novels.
Tony H is going to fucking
book the sex and politics.
Ex lives in headlocks the shoe
unauthorized bio of Vince Mcmahon.
What the fuck are you doing?
Reading awesomeness
about a guy who took a,
a joke of a show and turned it into a
billion dollar enterprise and wrote it all
himself and is the main, you should
read her book on pro wrestling. Dude,
you should write a book, a
love affair, pro wrestling.
I love affair from Tony Hinchcliffe.
I was listening to, um, to,
uh, the opening Anthony Show, which is
no longer the European Anthony show. Now.
It's a oop with Jimmy Norton.
I don't know why don't they just call it
the opion Jimmy show, but whatever. Um,
they had this guy on and
uh, he's an author. He's,
he wrote that a card
movie with Kevin Spacey.
He's written a bunch of 'em, a
bunch of different, uh, uh, books.
His name is Ben Mazur,
Rich Mazza rich. And uh,
he was talking about Russian
oligarchs and about what happened,
what went down and Russia during like,
uh,
the fall of the Soviet Union
were seven to nine people,
but soaked up 50% of
the economy of Russia.
Yeah. Seven, seven or nine,
somewhere in that number.
Like no more than 10 people literally
had 50% of the Russian economy and they
were just killing each other.
They would like kill each other
and take over their businesses.
Like if you had a competitor
of like you were coke,
you would send your army over to kill
Pepsi and then you would just own Pepsi to
wow. It's, it was the total
complete wild, wild west.
And I don't know if he's written a book
on this or he's gonna write a book on
this, but fucking amen. Listen to that
shit. I bet he has written a book on it.
I should find out what the book
is been as rich Ben Mezrich.
I wonder what the direction of the
economy and the trends in everything we're
before that exclusive group of people
took that over. Cause it's, you know,
it seems like we're sort of in a way,
heading that direction with our stuff.
The top whatever percent has
such a crazy of money compared
to the rest of everybody.
Yeah. Well it's close. You know,
were, were pretty bad. But, uh,
apparently it's nothing like Russia,
like the, these Russian oligarchs.
They just dominated.
They just figured out a way to completely
dominate the entire economy of a giant
country. I mean it's, it's listening
to him talk about, it was fascinating.
That shows different now
that Anthony's not there,
but Jimmy Norton is so fucking
interesting. Hysterical. And you know,
an obese doing a great job with it too.
It's still a great show.
This Guy Ben Mezrich was fascinating.
Fuck Russia man.
It's crazy. They were talking about Putin,
but what a gangster Putin had to be to,
to come back and lead the country
after he left. Like he led the country,
took off. Like they, they impose
some sort of a term limit,
came back like no term limit in
buck. Oh, he's back again. He's,
this is a second time running the country.
Like he installed some sort of a puppet
dictator or a puppet leader when he was
gone and then came back and he's a
former KGB agent. Like what the fuck man.
You know,
there's a guy that,
a professional wrestler named Marie
Seth that actually Putin on the don,
the mega tron and the Titan tron.
Uh,
every time he comes out and really
gets the crowd riled up. Mother Russia,
I promise I will defeat my victim for you.
And it gets the whole crowd to hate him.
And then I,
and then a guy comes out and uh,
he, it Rousseff usually wins.
They let the Russian guy when
cause it drives the crowd crazy.
And then you think anything
can happen after that.
I fuck my favorite thing is to
watch how you respond to me.
Talk About Russ, what's wrong with you?
You would love it and roll with you.
I wouldn't love it. You'd be
amazed. I'll bet you though.
I bet you if I showed you a
statistic of UFC fans being WWE fans,
I bet you'd be shocked because before
the UFC was all over everything.
And one of the only outlets that end,
by the way,
I've been with the UFC since the
beginning, you know what I mean?
Like I mean like watching
it since the hoist days,
since the voice and shamrock and all that.
And that's because it's,
even though it's two totally different
things, UFC is obviously an extremely,
you know,
crazy sport and WWE is
completely entertainment with
some injuries from time to
time.
Uh,
you know,
the, it was an outlet for anybody
that wanted some crazy stuff.
Okay.
Wwe and UFC fans.
I bet there's a lot.
I would bet you that I'm just going to
wait till you're done talking. This is it.
This is my, this is my
closing statement. Here it is.
I'll bet you that at least 70% of UFC
fans have been or are a WWE fan at some
point 70%.
I love when people throw a statistic
around where they have done zero research.
Just a random number, I believe 70. I
do it all the time by the way. Yeah. Uh,
70 I bet. Bet 90%. No, I did. They look,
it's not the God damn same.
One of them is real.
One of them people that are battling
for their life and the most difficult
contest and all the reports.
Another one is some weird fucking jerk
off thing that strange guys do when they
sit in front of the TV and pretend they
don't know it's fake, right? It's 10. No,
I know it's fake. Everybody knows
it's fake. You don't want to know.
You shut that part of your brain
off. When you watch it, you're like,
like a lizard. They went to immediately
to take a full time writers job.
I know it's fake. Even even if
you wrote it, you would still be
there while it happened going,
I can't believe.
I can't believe
you would.
You would have your fucking script in your
hand and you'd be jumping up and down,
spinning around in circles.
I can't believe prompt the undertaker.
Oh yeah.
I'm real and Grabow worlds collide.
Oh yeah. I never got to finish.
So I wrote a thing to wear
Kane,
the undertakers brother wrestled Brock
Lesnar at this wrestlemania coming up in
seven months or so and uh,
loses but undertaker comes back.
Tombstone pal drives Brock Lesnar and
they walk off together. Amazing Swan Song.
They wait
when you come up with a move.
Yeah.
For a guy to win with.
Do you take into consideration at all the
health of the person trying to attempt
that move? It's tough. You're right. Yeah.
It's tough because when Brock Lesnar
did that shooting star press flipped
through the air and landed on his
head. I've seen that. I've seen that.
Everybody see anybody like who knew about
Brock Lesnar, who was researching him.
Very likely if you were going through
like internet videos and stuff like that,
you would run into that video of him
flipping off the top rope and landing on
his head off 300 pounds of them landed
on his head bang and kept going.
Yeah. Crazy. I don't know how the fuck
you lived. I know if you watched that,
it looks like he's a dead man.
Yeah.
Wayne's on his fucking head. Yeah.
There's some stuff that just can't even,
they just probably an
inch either way and he's,
he can't move his legs and stuff,
but he survived it.
I don't know how he did it and then
how he went on to fight actually fight,
fight afterwards.
Was that a big blow to the WWE when they
realized that Brock Lesnar got fucked
up? I do at Brown pride tattooed on his
body. Oh No. I don't know what that is.
What's Black Brown? Oh,
Cain Velasquez. Oh No. Yeah.
I didn't know he had a brown pride tattoo.
How do you know him and not know he has
a brown pride tattooed on his chest.
It's a big point of contention.
I. Dot. I don't know.
I don't tell a lot of people who are
white people find it quite offensive cause
you could never fight with white
pride tattooed on your chest.
Hmm. That's interesting. Yeah.
Now that I'm just hearing about this
for the first time, that is uh, that's,
that's an interesting,
yeah.
You're alone only allowed to
be proud if you're minority.
If you're proud and you're a majority,
you're mocking everybody else.
You're gloating, you're, or you're
racist trying to hold back the others.
If you have black pride and no
one gives you a hard time at all,
you could have a tee shirt on,
on television that says black pride
and no one would have issue with it.
But if you went on like CNN
with a white pride shirt on,
they might fucking kill you
with rocks. Yeah, that's insane.
I never thought of that before. White
Man's been held down for a long time. Wow.
You want to go to the meeting now? What
meeting? The white pride meeting. Uh,
you're willing,
they're willing to join us in our ranks.
So you're asking me if I
think it messed up the WWE.
When Cain Velasquez beat Brock, I beat
him so easily. I think the entire,
I think Brock going into the UFC and
doing anything good whatsoever completely
helped the WWE and the WWE is Brock.
I think Brock Lesnar, no bullshit.
Brock Lesnar did it the right way.
Like if Brock Lesnar left the WWE and
dedicated himself to becoming the best
fighter in the world,
I mean like best striking coaches,
best Jujitsu coaches and overall coach.
Like a guy like Matt [inaudible],
Matt Hume,
like a John Crouch,
like a real MMA coach who's
going to go over your game.
A guy who's well versed in all the
variables when it comes to fighting like a
Duane Ludwig.
Go over your game inside and out.
Find out what they can fix it
and worked on him for years.
If someone did that with him
and then built him up, slow it.
You start out in the RFA started out
in these smaller organizations and then
eventually you work your way up to a
larger organization and then eventually
fight in the UFC when you have,
you know,
1520 fights instead of your second
fucking pro fight being against a former
world champion.
His second pro fight in the UFC
was against frank fucking mirror.
That's crazy. He fights heath
herring. He fights Frank Mir.
I mean that's just ridiculous. He's not
ready. He could have been great though,
right? He could have been an all time.
Great. Yeah, he could have been an all.
He's a real freak athlete,
like no doubt about it. When,
when he fought, he's herring was just
running heath hearing over and just like,
Holy Shit. The first time I saw him fight,
I saw it. I saw his first fight live.
I saw him fight in Hollywood.
He fought in La at a,
it was a k one event and
it was really bizarre man.
It's like Dennis Rodman was
there and they were talk,
everyone was talking shit about the UFC,
like they were trying to get,
they were trying to get,
um,
like some sort of publicity by
like talking shit about the UFC.
So they hired Dennis robbed.
And this was like right when Dennis Rodman
was coming off of those reality shows
where he's all fucked up on drugs and
you know, it had metal all over his face.
And he's like, yeah, UFC
ain't shit compared to carry
one. No, no, they didn't.
And it was the first time Brock
Lesnar ever fought. And, uh,
I just remember he took down this
guy, uh, I forget dude's name.
I'm sure it's here on his
website somewhere, but he, uh,
took down this kind of smashed him and
like in no time and I remember thinking,
Ooh, that is a lot to handle.
Like that's a big boy.
That's not a, that's not like, I
mean he's, he's fucking enormous.
That's not a small guy.
He's an enormous former
NCAA wrestling champion.
Like a real wrestler.
Yeah.
You know, he's, he's unbelievable.
And I mean if that bacteria
infection in his stomach,
that really almost killed him. I
mean it really almost killed him. Uh,
didn't happen. I think it could
have gone a few different ways,
but I think either way he would've gone
back to the WWF because you can make so
much money.
They're doing such less work and such
less training and I think he's sort of
into that, cause he, they
don't work him a lot.
They don't work him like other wrestlers.
He has a special deal where
he gets paid millions in,
has to show up maybe 20 times a year,
a couple of Monday nights, he's comes out,
pops corn, jumps up and down, goes back,
you know,
his manager does all the talking.
You can't beat my client and he's
just standing there looking cool.
And how can we move to the back?
He has a better deal than everybody else.
Cause he's Brock Lesner, he's the,
he's, he's known as a, you know,
a killer. Is he the guy that's
like the most respected God?
I can't believe I'm asking you to tell
me any questions and see the guys the
most respect. Ronda Rousey was at raw
on Monday with the four horse women.
I wonder why she was,
you think maybe she got paid for that,
but that's what they do. That's
what, yeah, yeah, yeah. Um,
that's the old thing.
Yeah. In 2075, this guy, Troy hung, he
was supposed to fight Choi Hong Man.
But uh, that guy got injured
and they replaced him with
a guy named min suit Kim.
And he crushed him in one minute
and nine seconds the first round,
and then his second fight
was against Frank Mir.
So ridiculous.
Yeah.
The 360 favorite video ever.
My favorite Internet video ever.
The buffer three 60 and that's when you
interview or does he do it between Brock
and Lesner? Yeah. Yeah,
it shows him right there.
Shows talking to Brock right there.
He made his debut in the UFC.
His first fight against Frank Mir.
Unfucking believable.
Yeah, that's what, that's
one of the craziest things
I've ever heard in my life.
And then he fought a heath herring
and his next fight. It's crazy.
Absolutely crazy.
The next fight after that,
he fought for the title and beat Randy
couture. Wrap your fucking head around.
That does wrap your head around that.
The guy fought twice in the UFC,
one against Frank Mir,
one against heath herring,
and then his next fight is
Randy couture for the title,
his fourth fucking fight in MMA. He Beats
Randy coture for the heavyweight title.
Legitimately knocked him out, dropped him
and stopped him on the ground. I mean,
that, that's just fucking crazy. Yeah.
Really is fucking crazy man.
He's a monster athlete and they have
the belt on him right now and it's,
it's good draws a lot of people.
It draws a lot of people in. Yeah.
And uh, you know, they made,
they wrote a great one for this last
one tip for him to win the championship.
He just completely dominated the good guy.
Normally it's a back and forth battle.
Whoa.
But this was completely one side.
It's something like 16 German suplex is,
and by the way,
that that guy's landing
on the back of his neck,
just like Brock and that
shooting star press.
Some of these were sloppy and
that Brock undertaker match.
He literally gave the undertaker
concussion. It was bad. It was sloppy.
It wasn't supposed to go this way. But
when Brock hits those German suplex is,
even though they're paying
them a lot of money,
he's nowhere near the technical wrestler.
Like the guys that were,
had been built in,
built in the machine.
So when he hits a German suplex and he
throws a man over his head, he's not,
the guys can land on their neck and head
and stuff and the undertaker was in bad
shape. So Brock, sort of one of the
guys that's sort of a liability,
like he can take a guy out even
though you don't want him to.
How many of those dudes have like neck
surgery? Almost all of them. Nick Foley,
who I opened up for a couple of weeks ago,
known as mankind.
Dude love Cactus Jack.
The multiple personalities restless
literally is having back surgery or right
now. Really? Yup.
And he's had something like a
47 broken bones. It's all real.
He's missing his right ear.
He, he's missing his ear.
What happened was here it fell off.
It fell off during a match.
This is the guy that took the dive
off the hell on the cell versus the
undertaker through it.
Yeah.
Oh, that guy. Nobody
fucking knows about that.
Right? Nobody knows. Nobody knows.
This is the guy that did
the thing we all talk about.
Yeah. I'm telling you, it was like the,
uh, it's like the nine 11 of the WWF,
so he's ear fell off.
Was it a cauliflower ear?
Was it that that happens in MMA
fight sometimes, yeah. Cause it's so,
you know what call it failure.
Yeah, I used to Russell's it, yeah.
When your blood leaks into your ear
it hardens and becomes like calcium.
And so like when people look at people
with like fucked up years from grappling,
those things are hard and sometimes when
they get hit it literally breaks the
skin and it tears off.
Like chunks of people's ears have fallen
off during fights and like landed on
the ground inside the octagon.
I wrestled for four years
in high school and uh,
my senior year I remember I didn't get
cauliflower ear but some stuff broke up
up there and the top of my right
ear was black for like a month.
And it really freaked me out.
I didn't,
I didn't ever look into what it was
they did was my coach is just like,
we'll put some extra
padding in your head gear.
And so I had one side that stuck
out more than the other side.
I always wear head gear,
man. I don't want the I,
the problem with cauliflowers
you, everybody's like,
yeah, makes you look tough,
but it also affects the way
you're hearing works, right?
Like the design of your ear evolution as
sort of created this thing that allows
you to best capture the sound around you.
It's like,
it's not like a cute look at the
reason why your ears shaped like that.
I always tell people,
take your ear and then take the top of
your ear and then fold it down and listen
to how different shit
sounds and then let it go.
Like take that and just cover it up and
then let it go when it's covered up.
That's how Randy coture
hears all the time.
Like that's what his hearing is like and
his ear hole is this tiny little thing
like, well, lead Ishmael is
this a famous Jujitsu fighter?
They call them the leg, his ears.
It's like he has too hard, like a,
like a mouse sized thing
stuffed into each ear.
It's like they open his ear up,
stuffed this hard mouse thing like so.
His whole is like so tiny. No Q tips for
that guy. He's not using any cute tips.
If he does,
he's a cute dude.
He's got a force that bitch in there
and you're never going to get it out.
It's like he's got little tiny
tiny holes. That's, that's bad.
You're not supposed to do
that. Yeah, but people like it.
They like it because it makes them look
like fucking bad asses. I don't know.
I think he's responsible for a lot of
fighters. Bad choices and walk in music.
Oh Wow.
Getting music by the way.
That's my favorite thing.
They probably have no idea
what they're listening to.
I love that part of everything.
Especially the UFC because it is so crazy.
Like the quiet before the storm and
some people pick the worst song.
Well you know what's fucked up?
This dude Roy Mcdonald's is one
of the top fighters in the UFC.
He's a top contender in the welterweight
division is bad motherfucker. Oh,
he's had bad walking music. Like one
time he came out to can't touch this.
I was mocking him. I had to, I was
goofing on it. I was like, ah, is this
great song back in the
day, by the way. Yeah.
Props to MC hammer frosty and I
have a thing has come and gone.
We always talk about we go,
we will make predictions right
off of that. Every single fight.
What happened was Rory wasn't
picking his walking music.
He changed his phone number.
He moved from Vancouver area to Montreal
and he changed his phone number and the
guy who got his old phone
number was a fan. Just a rant.
It happened to be a fan
because in Vancouver in that
area Colona where he's from
is fucking huge. He's a huge star.
Like when he fought in Vancouver,
people went nuts.
They were so psyched to see him there.
So this guy just happened to get his
phone number happened to be a fence when
they texted him, what do you want for
your walk up Music Rory? He's like, what?
Oh my God.
So he never told anybody and he
had this phone number for years.
He was giving shitty walking music to Roy.
We titled
that is Hilarious.
And then finally Rory called up
the number or something like that.
They were like finally figured out that
he wasn't really Rory. Wow. We're hey.
Like they said to Rory, you know we
get your text for all your song picks.
He's like, what? I'm not
sending any texts. Oh,
I didn't fucking say what
number were you texting?
And then he realized it was his
old number. That's so funny.
The guy must have been in
home just giggling like,
like a child when can't touch
this came on. He wants to be like
came touches dude.
You didn't walk in.
Music is so powerful because
you could psych out in yeah.
Opponent with walk in music if
it's done properly. If it's some,
if it's some subtle crazy
stuff, you know? No, you can't.
Little bit
me can wrestling. You're look around.
What is that trembling? He's playing that.
Who's that? Phil Collins.
I can feel it in here.
You think?
I believe this is my song.
I think if you're on, if you're fighting
in the UFC and you come out first,
you add your song.
Let's say your songs like a seven on a
one to 10 and then lights go out and Phil
Collins in the air tonight does come
in. You're not a little bit like, fuck,
I wish I would've picked
this guy he's already got,
he's already got one on me
is already willing to one
below. And that's the intro.
You
need to call Vince Mcmahon right now.
You think like a fucking pro
wrestling fan. Can I say that?
With all due respect? I'm not, I'm not
hating on it. But you think like you,
you take any joy in that stupidity. I
know I do. It's entertaining as hell.
Vince, why are you slipping?
This is the management.
Turn your organization around your them
either and they should call you the
mastermind and they should make you a
character as well. I agree with you.
Where those gold wrestling shoes, that's
your whole outfit. It's shiny gold.
I'm the mastermind. Good to
be here in Vancouver, right?
Oh, what's wrong? You don't
like my plans for the future.
I can feel it.
Oh my God. Yeah. There's an article.
Go on bloody elbow.com if you go to
bloody elbow.com and read about the,
if you're a UFC fan,
it's by our friend Crooklyn Stephie
Daniels who wrote this story about,
Oh, this imposter choosing Roy
McDonald's walk up music for years.
For fucking years. The dude did it. Oh,
oh my God. It's so funny, man.
Oh,
it even says how I was making fun of them.
Oh man, this sucks a little
bit. For folks who don't know,
I'm a big Roy McDonald Fan and you,
you actually hear his voice during the,
when you hear Joe Rogan podcast,
check it out. That's Roy. Oh,
that's him from one of the,
and then the other one is Nick Diaz
going train by day Joe Rogan podcast by
night all day. It's a greatest quote of
all time of my entire career by the way.
I just think this, this dude, I want to
interview this guy. Whoever the guy is,
he's hilarious, man. Whoever that dude,
but it's like he had a loopy fiasco,
light work. That was one of them.
Rihanna, we found love.
That was another one.
But he came in with good ones.
Like he had Metallica seek and destroy.
That's a good one, Huh?
Yeah. Hmm. Hmm. Hmm.
And then, uh, he had a violin
orchestra for one of them. I see.
I think that would be awesome.
Yeah. Why not, right? Yeah.
Just something different.
Something different. Make
the opponent wonder. Wow,
what's the psychological plan here?
What is it about all that stuff,
even though you know it's
total 100% horseshit.
What is it about that stuff that's
appealing to you? The Entertainment Gel.
If you watch one of these things,
you would,
you would see what you liked about it and
you would have a few favorites and no,
no.
I'd go fucking crazy.
And I'd watch lions killing gazelles
on television because that's real.
That's what I'd do. I'd grab my
laptop and I'd be like, yeah,
you watched this fake shit all
day. I need real, I need real.
I can't get entertained by
frank, but that's what TV
shows. The movies are there.
Fake. No, no, they're not.
Fake sports are real
and that I understand,
and this is sports entertainment.
It's not, it's not. We're not.
Nobody's saying it's really when you
watch game of Thrones and you watch a guy
get his head cut off, you
know what it looks like. Yeah.
It looks like a guy actually getting
his head cut off. It looks real.
When I watch wrestling and
I see a guy get hit and go
turned to the crowd, I know
that's bullshit. Right?
It's offensive to me.
It's offensive. Yeah,
and the idea is other moves that happen
that are amazing. Nope. Nope, nope.
They're all offensive. Oh No. I know
they take athleticism to pull off,
but they're offensive
because I'm so aware.
It's so in my face that this
is not really happening.
I can't be the guy in the gold
suit holding on to the script,
jumping around and place going.
Her lost the streak has bed proud again.
That's what you would do. You would freak
the fuck out. He wouldn't run around.
I wouldn't do that.
You would if you were hired.
If I had a gold suit I would do that,
but I don't have a cold.
I can see you doing it.
Vince is fucking up.
Really needs to make you a part of it.
I told him Tony when
immediately you should do it
and I can't believe you didn't
take it Tony cause that is the leg one
of the biggest things for for you because
you are that. That's what trying to
negotiate doing it part time from La.
That would be awesome.
That would,
that would be best for both sides because
I wouldn't get burned out on it and
they would have awesome,
great ideas that are hip and cool and I
would have been able to do what I wanted.
Hip and cool. Whenever guys says
my ideas are hip and cool, I'll go.
Are you sure the pins,
what ideas he's talking about has a scarf.
Scarf. It's a scarf with
little skulls all over it.
Like he's a pirate and he's
drinking a Frappaccino.
Are you ever saw this one caring?
Yes.
Undertaker has gone.
Metro,
Metro, sexual undertaker.
Maybe if you changed.
All of a sudden Tony starts working for
them and every character becomes gay and
it turns out that there's someone
who's sprinkling gay dust overall.
The other competitors where there in
the locker room, there's, he's turning.
That's the, that's a plot that Tony comes
up when he turns the entire roster gay.
It turns out there's an openly gay
wrestler and he has gay fairy dust. Okay,
well he was, he didn't like a
leprechauns ball sack. You read,
kill the Leprechaun and turned
his ball sack until like this.
Are you ready for this?
What if I were to tell you that there is
an openly gay wrestler that blows dust
in people's spaces? Fuck that. His
name is gold dust. No fucking way.
There he is right there. Yeah, Dude.
This is in the WWE. Dustin
Rhodes, a third generation rest.
What's going on with his Dick?
That's gold dust.
You've heard a horsepower
that's like related to the
dusty roads? Yeah. Yeah. Hey,
how did it, how did she know about
that? See Rhodes to be eight.
This shit made sense.
Thank you Jeff.
This guy's real. Please.
I need to see more.
I can't believe I invented a guy
that already exist. Yeah you can.
You should be writing this.
That's him and his uh,
insurance cell phone when he
takes off the wagon robe and he
flirts with them in the ring and Shit
blows and kisses and they get all riled up
and then he can beat him with shit
cause they were like all I'm not gay.
Get away from me. And he's like, oh
yeah, come here. Beautiful. And they're
did the WWE,
he should hire Michael Sam as soon
as he's done with the Dallas cowboys.
He's the openly gay NFL
player. I don't, I don't know.
He's not good enough to make the team
and just bringing them for the practice
squad.
They need to bring that dude into
WWE and actually fuck a guy on TV.
Well him and gold dust. Yeah, but gold
does is faking it. I could tell it.
Look it up. My Guy Straight. Yeah,
he's super straight. Is super straight.
That's the cat whisperer guy, isn't it?
The same actor guy as the cat whisperer.
What's the cat whisperer? The TV show.
What's that? It's a show where this,
it's like the dog whisperer,
but for cats. Oh God, really?
Here's how you fix it.
Cat Rocks.
Dusty Rhodes is his dad and he has
a brother named Cody Rhodes funk.
Problem solved. I actually have a
coyote issue, my neighborhood now,
cause I have so many chickens.
These coyotes are circling
my house on a daily basis.
Every time I come home there's coyotes
around my gate now. Oh Shit. It's creepy.
Fucked your chickens ever wake up in the
middle of the night and wake you up. No.
Chickens don't wake up at night. They
sleep all night. In fact, you can go,
I can go in the chicken house
at night and just pick them up.
They're just sitting there. You just
grab them. I pick them up and him. Yeah.
Don't make a little more
in south central.
Are they just all night long or is
that roosters? Roosters, yeah. Yeah.
That's Mexican guys. Love
it. I don't say this,
you know, I'm not generalized sizing
generals, Isaac's generalizing,
but a lot like my friend, my friend,
uh, I don't want to say his name.
He's a older gentleman that happens
to be a, a guy I've known for decades.
Mexican dude. He, he keeps
roosters in his yard. Like he has,
I want to say he has a hundred chickens.
It's close to a hundred chickens. Wow.
And he uses him for fighting.
Like they gamble on it.
It's just been a part of their culture
for as long as they can remember a
hundred chicken,
they have like an arena that has like
a barn and they take these friends come
over, they cook a goat, they could
goats and a, it's really crazy.
Like that's also a normal
part of their culture.
And he was renting a house once and
he was telling me the story of how
ridiculous it was.
And he was like a,
they got in trouble for butchering
of goat cause someone, uh,
someone called it in on them and you know,
the,
the landlord said you can't do that.
You can't butcher goat is like,
it's not weekly. We left
home alone, you know,
so he didn't like cut it open and just
leave the guts out so the neighborhood
smells it. He goes like, he's
like, we eat it. Yeah. And he goes,
but I could cook hamburgers in my yard
and no one have a problem with it.
But he was like, but this goat,
like I know how healthy it is.
I know that it's, it's good
meat. I know how fresh it is.
Like we kill that goat and then they
roast it. They have like a, like a,
like a barbecue and a bunch of guys would
come over and they would eat goat and
get drunk and have rooster fights.
Wow. Yeah. And it's a tall,
I mean we think it's fucked up,
but it's a total normal part of their
culture. Yeah. And they eat the chickens.
I mean, after it's all over,
it's kind of fucked up.
Cause they do make these chickens fight
to the death. But after it's over,
they turned him into soup.
But so it's like, I, you know,
part of me says it's animal
cruelty of the, the biggest part.
Like my gut reaction. I look at
that. Should that be legal? Wow.
Oh that's kind of a fucked up thing to do.
It's kind of a fucked up thing to put
razor blades in the end of a chicken's
foot and stick them in a cage and
another chicken. They fucking, yeah,
they should just do fake chicken
fighting. See, I'm a gay chicken.
Come Alvin the blonde wig and
all right guys. I lost Sean that
it's gotta be real chicken.
Can't believe it's gold guys real.
I came up with a guy who blows dust.
No, his dad, you named it dusty Rhodes.
Let them know that he exists and he's
got a brother named Cody Rhodes who just
made the jump to being star
dust, which is the, uh,
he's like the,
he's like another version of gold
dust except up now they roll together.
So he's gay too.
Now star dust is more like,
just like about the cosmos and like,
ah,
I just can't believe all
the magical things. So yeah.
So he's high. Yeah. So he's
like a stone or stone to the
gills. Oh, that's so funny.
Except he's just on, you never know.
Do you think that it's possible to,
Tony could get me to like pro wrestling?
Yes. Oh, I know for a fact, dude.
I would know. I knew the exact
match is the videos, the moves,
the everything that would, that would
interest you or see too much real.
There's some crazy submission moves that a
no, no, no, no, no. That was the last day.
That's the last thing you want to show me.
Don't that'll get me angry.
I'd be like, that wouldn't work,
right. No defense here. Hip Escape.
He can get out of there.
Nothing drives me crazier than like
a fake submission move in a movie.
That shit drives me nuts.
You know,
I stopped watching Dexter because fucking,
what's his name from third rock? John
Lithgow. John Lithgo have this chicken,
a rear naked choke in a bathtub and he,
and he killed her that way and I was like,
oh my God,
that's the worst fucking room naked
choke I've ever seen. That's so fake.
She's not even red. I'm
done. And I shut it off.
I walked out of the room and discussed
and I'd never watched another episode of
Dexter again. Wow. Yeah. You can't
show me a fake rear naked choke.
You fucks that.
That makes me angry.
That's like if you were
watching a Jimi Hendrix bio,
pick a non bio pic,
but like a you one of those
movies where it's a fake look.
An actor plays Jimmy Hendrix. I
guess that's a bio pic, right? Yeah.
And some do didn't know how to play
guitar and he's like Kinda around. Yeah,
and you'd be like, no, y'all got
doing it. You're not doing it at all
playing guitar.
That's what John Lithgow is Shitty
fucking Renee get choked did for me.
The only reason I think you would maybe
like it in the future is that you like,
you know,
UFC so much an MMA and Jujitsu so much
and Tony gets it together with a bunch of
people and watches it.
A lot of them watch it as a joke and
where Tony I think takes it a little bit
serious tone. We all watched it
as a joke. I can I not buying,
I joke.
I just see and recognize
what's entertaining about it
and I do like the ideology
of stunning and arena of people.
Sometimes that happens,
it can happen.
You have to look at the reaction is the
three hour like job interview for you.
This is like your audition tape.
They should fucking hire you.
They should figure it out. I need you
to pull this up. Where are you, man?
Listen, take the needle out of your ass
and hire this guy. You're crazy not to.
You should have seen the
looks on these people's faces.
When Brock Lesnar beat the undertaker,
nobody thought it was going to happen.
Oh my God, what did they do, Tony?
Imagine if on Saturday the
fuck is wrong with you.
Nobody thought it was going to happen.
It was amazing. It was fake as fuck dude.
But nobody thought it was going to happen.
A lot of things are fake that nobody
thought was going to happen. Tony, Tony,
Tony at the time,
imagine if that guy who filled in for
that shit's gay on Saturday and he took on
Dillashaw.
Imagine if in the miracle he was able to
somehow land a punch on Dillashaw beat
him, the place would have been. I mean,
well it's sort of weird cause that's
Sacramento and that's Dillashaw his
hometown. But I'm just saying
like in a neutral field,
that would have been stunning and
everybody would have known that they just
witnessed history. Tony,
that would have been real.
Right. It wasn't even real
to really happen movement.
It really knocked out a professional
athlete to guys who've trained to fight
their entire lives.
It's real. Right, right.
I understand you. You're
so crazy. You, by the way,
this stuff is trying
to sell insurance here.
I understand where your concerns are,
but let me just show you the details
of our policy. You're a crazy person.
No,
I'm telling you why
there's millions and millions
of WWE and I'm telling you why.
Maybe hunters Thompson was just a couple
of decades off when it was predicting
the end of the world. Those guys, they
mean it's not easy. If, for example,
Brock was furious when Vince told him
that he wanted him to beat the undertaker
that day, like in real life like Betty
was, and you were there to see it. No,
but I talked to somebody who was,
oh, I bet he was honest with you.
It's not like they lie all day. Every
day. Tony's going to talk to some people.
Let me tell you a little, I'll tell
you what. Brock was actually mad.
He was really mad. He had read the script
and you just start. Dose is bullshit.
I'm not picking a fuck. You don't
undertake some of the guys that work.
Unlike the technical side for the UFC
work for the WWE heard Brock was crying.
That's what I heard was Brock went
to the hospital with the undertaker,
cried, so hardy dehydrated
himself. After that match,
they had to give them an IV to replenish.
His team thought he killed
the undertaker from that
Kachin. It was bad, bad. It was real.
The concussions are real.
You can't, you can't,
I don't even buy it was a real concussion.
They probably faked a concussion.
Take her to the hospital.
He's got up oboe and even
on the real booboo folks,
if you don't think it's a real blue blah,
show you the fucking band aid on it.
My four year old
pitching something at four year olds,
so booboo,
it is a booboo and need up their day.
Honey, there's no, he's not even
bleeding. You don't need a bandaid. Oh,
I want a bandaid. Okay, well
band, they make you feel better.
We'll get you a bandaid. It took the
undertaker and put a bandaid on them.
Tony Hinchcliffe in a gold
suit holding the script.
I can't believe it's our real,
he's jumping up and down and circles
and Vince Mcmahon is stand there shaking
his head.
Color of purple.
I'll fucking pent up with rage.
That's how I it
down. It's a booboo. Look at the
bandaid. It's real. It's a real bandaid.
Ladies and gentlemen, if you doubt
it. What else do you like? That sucks.
Um, let's see. What else
do I liked? It sucks. Uh,
I guess I play fantasy football. I
don't talk about that a lot. Well,
fantasy football is at least
based on fucking football, right?
Which is a real game. People are
really trying and shit really happens,
but nobody knows what's going to
happen in real sports. My God.
Isn't that part of what makes it exciting?
You fucking Weirdo.
Same thing about the eat. Oh Shit.
He don't know what's going to happen.
You don't know what's going to
happen. You predicted a writer? No.
The writer knows what's going to happen.
Oh, the writer knows it's not real.
It's like a play.
Do you like musicals now?
I've been the one gay or than musicals.
How about that? That doesn't make sense.
Sure it does. It's dudes are
hugging. They get all sweaty.
They're laying on each other.
They're an and it's not real. Okay.
I mean, after musicals guys
are banging, but do you know,
I don't know if they're banging.
I don't go to those things.
I'm not in that world. You've
seen a musical, right? Yeah.
I've seen a bunch of musicals. Not that
there's anything wrong with being gay,
by the way, but musicals are gay. They
just are. It really is. It really is.
Unless it's a humorous musical.
Yeah.
Even then it's even then he made
someone kisses ass. Right. Uh,
that's someone else. That's a Photoshop,
isn't it? Yeah. That's not the real,
who's that guy?
That's a fake guy.
Probably one of you out there.
We'll just go look for it.
That's the thing about the Internet,
man.
There's a photo of you
out there somewhere.
Someone's Photoshop to Dick in your
mouth or you kissing ass or you doing
something ridiculous and over my Mustang,
but why did he do that as a challenger?
Why did he do that?
Why he pulled his pants down and made
someone kisses ass on TV? Probably.
That sounds like something he
would do, but he did. You know it.
Why are you pretending
you didn't watch that one?
It spits back thinking they think
that was over like 1213 years ago.
Something like that. You weren't
there yet, Huh? No, I can't remember.
I can't remember. I don't believe
it. I think you're being mocked.
That may have been during the period
where, why don't you guys kissed his ass?
Fuck your brother.
Backyard wrestling.
Kind of gauge how many people in
the audience though. That's insane.
Plus it's been winning the Monday
night cable wars for over 20 years.
Think about that for a second.
Every Monday night at wins,
every single month they pulled TNA
though. They pulled TNA from, yeah,
from a spiky expenses competition.
What's the problem with TNA?
I'm just not good enough. Everything's
terrible. They're just completely,
it's not even in the snow. That's what
it should be. Bribed. But it's not,
it's not even in the same
ballpark. What is it? Well,
they used to have like a lot
of the MMA guys would do it.
Like King Mo was in TNA and rampages
and TNA. There's not good. No, no.
That's wrong with it. Bad writing, bad
everything. Could you go over there?
Maybe ma'am,
yes or no?
I don't want you don't turn
down the WWE TNA. Listen,
you could be the fucking mogul. What
do they give you a piece of the action.
What is DNA said? Listen, we heard
you on the Joe Rogan podcast.
We'd liked the way you
think about wrestling.
I think this organization has still
has some life and we're willing to uh,
willing to cut you in on this. Give you
10% of the action. I don't own 10% of TNA.
I'm pretty sure 10% of the TNA wouldn't
even get me what I would have made with
the WWE. You son of a bitch.
Yeah. They just lost the TV deal.
They don't have a TV deal.
Yeah,
they're done and maybe it'll
get picked up by like lifetime.
Vince Mcmahon beat Ted Turner.
What does Ted Turner, CNN, CNN,
TNT, TBS heat through Ted Turner
at open checks that he would,
he would just sign any
wrestler back and uh,
they were having wars on Monday nights.
They'd go against each other. Vince,
WWE on the USA network and TNT
had nitro and Ted Turner said,
whatever we need to do
to beat Vince Mcmahon,
I will write the check to
whoever's they offered.
They bought hall Kogan they
bought all these, this, he
believes this. I was there.
I was in the room.
No,
I didn't say I was there and he'll just
willing to spend whatever it takes.
That sounds like a plot, like a
plot in like two different, no, I'm,
this is where it's real. Just
part's real. That's the problem.
You've cried wolf through
this whole podcast.
I never said it was really also about
Santa Claus repeating that it's not real
and I'm agreeing with you and now you're
trying to tell us that the boogie man
is real. That's what you're
doing. Wrestling. So real.
I said that it's going to write it.
How much did Ted Turner spin
millions and millions to buy good.
The guys that were already
developed from the WWF,
he bought all their biggest guys
hoodie by Hulk Hogan. A macho man.
Randy Savage, you know,
macho man, dusty Rhodes.
I'm a slim Jim Fan. Right.
Snapping list. Then shit,
dusty Rhodes, he bought
them all. And how did it do,
they ended up winning the wars for
a bunch of weeks in a row. They did.
Yeah. It turned it. Yeah. For
like a year in a row. And uh,
but then Vince,
uh,
bought Mike Tyson and made him referent
match at Wrestlemania with Steve Austin
and shut Michelson that it dominated. The
rest is history. That's it. One move. Yup.
You know,
that's all it takes.
Sometimes just one move like Hugh grant
being on tonight show was what won the
tonight show the rating more and
it was like this rating more.
And then Jay Leno got Hugh grant on after
Hugh grant got busted with a squeaker
gas
dot. Merera would say, okay. Yeah.
Scag it black prostitutes ticket.
Skanky yeah. Remember that chick?
He got up and you could, uh, she was
advertising online like as a hooker,
like for the longest time. I know
if it still is, but like escort,
like this was the girl who got arrested
with you, grant that you could fuck her.
Like that was like the selling point.
And that one thing when Jay Leno
had him on the couch, he goes,
what the hell were you thinking?
Yeah. That one on the ratings war.
How that happens. Like that
crazy. What do you, oh,
because it's amazing that, uh, you know,
I just liked David Letterman a lot
more than Jay Leno and to think that,
you know,
using some scum buckets,
scummy life is a launching pad that Jay
can pass up a guy like Letterman and
by scum buckets, gummy life.
I'm talking about Hugh Grant,
awesome dude who takes crazy chances
that are entertaining. Like Hugh grant,
really,
if it wasn't for that,
a lot of people got a lot of enjoyment
out of the fact that he got busted with a
hooker.
I don't think it's good what he did,
but I don't necessarily think
it's bad either. You know,
he wanted something dangerous in his life.
He's a movie star.
He's living in this
fucking ridiculous life.
He has that beautiful woman for a
wife. What was her name? The one the,
the same chick who was involved recently,
Elizabeth Hurley. Remember God damn,
she was hot, but it's ridiculously
hot. He's like, I don't care.
I need something dangerous.
You got a streetwalker. What
did anything Murphy do? Trains.
Does anybody talk about that? Like
how does that never get brought up at,
he gets brought up. Why Eddie
Murphy doesn't go on stage anymore.
I guarantee you that you're probably
connected. It's gotta be right.
That's got to mess with them.
Dude.
I was at a comedy show with Charlie
Murphy and some dude was heckling from the
audience by cackling Charlie
Murphy and Charlie was,
Charlie got real with the guy.
You know,
like the guy said something to him and
Charlie was like, yeah, yeah, listen,
that's my brother and I'll fuck you.
It was like really that simple.
It's like all the comedy got dropped and
then the dude was in the audience and
you realize, I know he's only about 30 or
40 feet between him and Charlie Murphy.
Like that's a real person.
You can't just,
you can't just mock a guy's brother
like that and not expect something to go
have go wrong. Yeah. Yeah. My
friend, uh, I won't say his name,
but uh,
it was one of the police officers that
was involved in one of those altercations
with Eddie Murphy where there was
once he was helping a gentleman home,
a gentleman that likes
to dresses ladies and uh,
it was just trying to help somebody out.
No big deals. Big Best understanding.
And your friend's a cop. My
friend Beverly Hills Cop, he uh,
worked for the police force.
I don't believe it was Beverly hills,
but I guess it's okay. Got It. Banana
in the tailpipe.
It's a banana in the tailpipe.
Trick
for me as a, as a comic,
like as a young comic,
I can't imagine how guys, like we
talked about this yesterday with dom,
how guys just stop. Like with
Steve Martin, they just stop.
But to be a guy like
Eddie Murphy and stop.
If you ever go back and watch Eddie
Murphy delirious. It's hard because it's,
it's difficult for those things to
hold up today like they did back then,
but when I was a kid and
like whatever a year it was,
maybe it was like 86 or something like
that where Eddie Murphy delirious came on.
He was a destroyer of worlds.
He was so funny.
We were over.
My friend Jimmy lost his house.
You're watching it with Jimmy and John
Battle Rocco and John's sister and I
think a bunch of people there.
We were crying. Laughing. Yeah.
At Eddie Murphy delirious.
We couldn't believe how funny it was.
It was just insane.
Oh my God.
It's a funny is before I ever even
thought about doing standup comedy and the
idea that that guy is still around
by the way, looks fantastic. Yeah,
I was going to say that's the red leather,
right? Yeah, no, what I mean today,
it looks fantastic. I saw Eddie
Murphy in Maui about two years ago.
Just totally random. I was there with my
family and I ran into a Eddie's cousin,
uh, at the, uh, at the desk, at the check
in desk and was like, what's up dude?
What are you doing? He's like, Oh shit,
Charlie's here. You know, go say hi.
And so we went over and said Hi.
And he's with Eddie Murphy.
Eddie Murphy looks like he's
30 years old. Wow. I mean,
I don't know how old he is now. He's
gotta be in his fifties right? Yeah.
Because when I was
18 or something like that,
19 delirious came out and he was,
he got here like 24, 25 back then.
So he's gotta be in his fifties.
He looks fucking great. Yeah.
So whatever he's doing,
keep it up.
Yeah. It's black skin too though. Yeah.
Black people have black don't crack,
you know, straight the way better
aging. Like really blonde folks,
you know, like a, those
really Nordic looking,
those motherfuckers wrinkle up like
an old catcher's Mitt. Yeah. Oh,
just turns in on itself.
It's oily skin like,
like the dark and dark skin to cause that
dark skin doesn't get fucked up by the
sun. You know, Melanin,
Melanin protects you from all the shit
that white people are always worried
about. You know, they're always
putting fucking sunscreen on. Yeah.
That's why like you can like
look at Oprah. How old is she?
She looks great with the makeup on
in real life. You don't think so? Oh
No. Uh, if it's,
if people saw what Oprah looked like
in real life, she'd be dealing with,
uh, she'd be in the next
WWF superstar. Amazing.
That Oprah is one of the
few people that's gotten by.
Like few people.
That's a woman without ever
selling herself as a sexual object.
You got like your Barbara Walters
characters. He got like your
news people and you've got Oprah.
Well, she's never had a
choice. Right? She's never,
it's pretty easy to not be a sex
object when you can't be a sex object.
She's like one of them
main points against the,
you know,
the only way a woman gets on television
if she's like the biggest fucking,
if you, if you had a deal, you
got to like look at biggest stars,
like biggest stars in the country. She's
top 10 of the everyone doing everything,
whether they're singers, whether
they're actors, top 10 and I mean,
she's done some acting like
she was in the color purple,
but you can't really call her
an actor. Right. You know,
she's really just a personality.
And just from being a personality,
she's one of the most famous
people ever. Yeah. Tony,
would you fuck Oprah or Ellen?
Okay.
Um,
I or both.
If you had a choice between either or or
both. I would have to be Allen. I mean,
really a no brainer either or. Both
of you seen Oprah with no makeup? No.
But have you done accessing?
Okay.
Have you ever done ecstasy?
I think you'd do both.
No.
I know I would
have chosen love with
Oprah. Right. So, I mean,
it depends if like, am I at,
am I in Oprah's, you know,
a $30 million compound. I might be
more a little more easily swayed,
you know what I mean?
Be like a girl would be if
she went over a guy's house,
he picked her up in a
Lamborghini and drove her.
Pretty sure Oprah is a
billionaire with a B man.
There's something a little bit hot about
that it, there you go. Look at that.
Or she is, fuck yeah. For all of
you that have ever wanted a bone,
a rampage Jackson.
Oh my son
can't believe it.
You're a terrible person.
I have always made fun of people.
I like, I like picking on people.
You, you almost play a character.
You play kind of like a evil person.
So you're almost playing
a wrestler in real life.
Yeah. I say I like, uh, I like
picking on people. That's my move.
That's your move. If
you're a wrestler, yeah.
He'd be the guy that gets
under everybody's. Yeah.
Yeah.
Sticks and stones. I want to break
your bones, but my words will hurt you.
I want to take you back.
Tony, do you remember this?
Oh yeah, I do remember that so clearly.
Wow.
Okay.
This is an interesting time to drop this.
Wow.
Now to most people,
this is just shitty fucking music.
Okay.
People were complaints
so hard or my message,
I played this I love, I
was like, I understand the
grateful dead now.
I really do get it.
I never got what everybody was into with
the grateful dead until I did DMT with
this plane in the background. By the
way, a fighter comes out to this music,
that fighter in the rings like,
fuck man,
I don't want him to fucking fight
this guy. This is some shade. Yeah.
This guy's got extra pack and some
extra confidence. I worked out to this.
Really? Yeah. Yeah. Put
me in a weird place, man.
I was high as fuck.
Yeah,
you can get high and listen to this and
it takes you like really close to that
place.
That's what's fucked up.
It's like you have some weird
memory of like psychedelic trips.
Yeah. But when you have a psychedelic
trip that's connected to music,
when you hear the music again,
can recall some of the psychedelic trip.
I remember specifically the
last time I heard this song,
I was watching 70 pope's do the robot
pope's pope hats.
Wow.
Anyway,
there it goes.
That a WWE writing Gig,
right?
No, you're going to come
in as the wizard. Now.
You're going to come in as the showman.
Uh,
you're going to bring in Sharmans to
change change the course of events.
That was pretty intense,
Huh?
Tony didn't have any plans on doing DMT
either until we went to Texas until 40
minutes before it happened. Yeah. Yeah.
You weren't sure if you're going to do
it or not. Yeah. I didn't bring it up.
Brought it up like right before you
want to do this. And he was like, what?
[inaudible] which is the best way to do
it. Yeah. Don't think about that shit.
Just dive in. Especially DMT. Yeah.
But, but if you're worried about it,
don't do it. Right. But you did it.
Anything that lasts a 10 or 15
minutes, I could always do. Yeah.
But that 10 or 15 minutes
will change everything. Yeah.
So much fun.
What was surprising about it?
Um,
uh,
just the,
just the overall visions and craziness
and the mellow chillness of everything
and it was just a very cozy
environment and everything.
The experience.
Okay.
What did you expect versus
what it actually was?
MMM.
I didn't expect much. I don't know
anything about it, so I didn't know it.
I don't know anything about it going
into it. That's really crazy. Yeah.
That's probably why I just knew that
I had done mushrooms four days before,
so I'm like, all right, perfect.
You are primed. Here we go.
Yeah. As a part of Ari Shaffir
shroom fest, which is by the way,
growing people are doing it
all over the world and my God,
he announces that people,
people get on shrooms all over the world.
During that same week,
we had so much fun man.
That night that I went there,
there was a meteor shower and all out
meteor shower and it was like a plan thing
all over the news like media
shower tonight if you just
so happen to look at the
right time.
And we're out in the middle of the
desert where if there is a shoe you see,
you see a shooting star on a non meteor
shower night once every few minutes.
And this was just a shower of meteors
with a super moon because that's what he
scheduled shroom fest around.
So supermoon meteor shower,
lightening storm miles away
and one patch of the desert,
just lightening crazy beautiful
bolts and a cloud's supermoon and um,
and then when the sun came up,
you know,
it's that weird desert thing where it's
still dark on one side and there's a
moon and the sun coming up on the other.
And a nice warm shower. Rain started.
We were just like in heaven. We were just
cracking up for seven hours straight.
It was insane. And I've done three shroom
fest with Ari and I've always said,
you know, it's, it's better than
Christmas, it's the best holiday
did.
There's something beautiful about getting
together with a bunch of people having
that kind of an experience together.
Just wish you could do it without
actually having to take something.
Savani worked. Mckenna had
a, an interesting take on
that. He's like, you know,
people that want to do it naturally.
You know,
people want to do it through yoga
or meditation. He's like, he goes,
I don't ever want to be able to access
these places accidentally. Right.
Because like there's so titanic,
Lee Alien,
I want to take something that
gets me there. Yeah. And he, he,
his take on it was that everybody has
this problem with taking a psychedelic
that the idea of letting
go and taking something,
it's just too scary because we
always hear about people overdosing,
which certainly can happen
with a lot of drugs.
It doesn't happen with most psychedelics,
but people do have adverse reactions.
They do. They do like freak
out. It can absolutely happen.
But his take on the idea of trying to
get there without the drug is just s he
was like, it's so silly, it's, you know,
you can get there
instantaneously with the drug,
but everybody always wants to do it on
their own, you know? Right. There's like,
can I can do it naturally,
I can achieve those. I've,
I've talked to people that are like a
dent against psychedelics but want to
achieve psychedelic states
and they were just like,
I can get their natural and like,
I don't know if you can,
you might be able to get there,
but you can't stay there.
Like I've done transcendental meditation.
I've worked hard.
There's been a couple of periods in my
life where I worked hard at it and just
like any muscle,
you get better at it and yeah,
if you get good at it and you're into
it and you're in the right setting,
2030 minutes in of going
over and over again, you,
you're gone into that type of state,
but your brain immediately goes,
Whoa, you're in that state. Come back
into your back. You're like, whoa.
I was just somewhere for two seconds.
So you can get there,
but you can't really stay there like you
can with some help where you're in it
for a few hours.
Right.
But is that because you're not a practice
guru or a practice traveler in those
mental worlds? Isn't it possible
that there could be a way,
like the thing that gives me
hope is Kundalini. Cause my
friend Denny, uh, who's a,
he's a Kunal Indians, Cuna Lien
Kundalini instructor, and he's a,
he's practiced it for years and he's
done a bunch of psychedelics as well.
He told me that he's a bit,
he's able to achieve those states that
he can get to a state of hallucination,
like psychedelic hallucination.
He can literally get to a state where
his mind starts pumping out psychedelic
chemicals. He says, not
easy though, and you know,
but he's been doing it every day for
years. Wow. And he can get there.
So I think when, when someone, like
you says, you know, you, you get there,
but then you go, oh my God,
I can't believe I'm there.
I can totally relate to that because
I've been in there in the isolation tank
before.
There was one time I was in the
isolation tank where had this crazy
hallucination that I was a in some weird
tribe and these people in this tribe,
we're talking in a language that was
completely foreign but I could understand
it and I was even thinking
in their language and then
I realized it. I was like,
oh my God. I'm thinking in that language.
Then woke right up and it was over,
but I'll never forget that
because that moment I was like,
it seems so fun like that I could possibly
venture into some completely alien
civilization,
alien to me where I didn't know
anything about how they were talking.
I didn't know anything but I could
understand it and it was almost like this
window to what what communication
really is that communication.
Although languages very
and although cultures vary,
there's a thing that's going
on when you're communicating.
Like when you and I are talking right
now does that thing that's going on and
you can tap into that thing,
whatever that thing is,
you can tap into that thing and
you do it with language. But in my,
my crazy hallucination inside the tank,
I tapped into it with my mind and I
was locked in there and although I
understood what they were saying I
shouldn't have, it was very, very strange.
It was a very,
very strange because it wasn't as
simple as I was pretending that I could
understand what they were saying.
Like in my mind they were noises that
were coming out of their mouth were there
were rough reflecting in my mind.
My,
I was giving interpretations on those
noises and those noises were like,
they were there. They were normal for
like a normal communication like hey,
we've got to go down to the river and
we've got to pick up some water and be
careful because there's a snake that
someone saw that's near this log.
It was like that kind of shit,
but it was in a completely different,
but I didn't know what, you know
some weird fucking language though.
But it's always the same thing.
Like whenever you have something that's
really trippy that happens when you're
meditating or really trippy that
happens when you're dreaming.
It's very difficult to stay in
that state and not go, oh my God,
I'm having a lucid dream
and then you wake up. Yeah,
it's hard to do all that stuff. One of
the interesting things about shrimp fest,
when you're doing it with a bunch of
Comedians and you forget that you know,
you're out in the desert with seven guys
and sometimes you're all sort of like
spread out on a mountain top.
You know what I mean?
And sometimes we're together laughing,
but sometimes we would like break apart
and then you forget everything that's
happening and then all of a sudden
something hilarious happens. You know?
Like at 1.1 guy was like,
and we're in the middle of the desert,
like phones don't even work out there,
but I didn't know where you just here
because it's so quiet. It's beautiful,
quiet desert and you just hear one guy
go, oh shit, I just got a Tinder match.
Everybody just started dying
in the desert is trying to get laid.
Oh exactly.
And I mean so far away from civilization.
It's so funny like guys and
their desire to get laid.
I wonder if girls have the
same sort of conversations,
like constantly trying to figure
out how like single girls,
how they can get some Dick.
It's one of the
thing that we're,
one of the things that I really,
it really annoys me sometimes
if if a buddies too horny,
it annoys the shit out of me.
Worst is if you have a friend where
that supersedes everything. Yeah.
Like you go out with them and
they'll like, they'll like,
you're supposed to all be hanging
out together and they'll leave,
they get a booty call, they'll
leave, they get a text hanging out,
swiping on Tinder or they're,
you know, just, you know,
Jamie, this motherfucker heats
the entire time you're in Denver.
He never put his phone down and I was
encouraging my fucking comedy special and
he's in the green room. Go
over as Tinder matches. I was,
I was guilty of encouraging that though
because she really looks like this and
like get the fuck away from me.
Joe, you're shooting, you're
special in ten nine Joe,
what do you think about this chick?
She's missed too much makeup.
She's a kindergarten teacher.
Oh, it's probably a freak.
What is it?
The Tinder is like the number one and
then there's grinder for the gay folk.
Is there one that's like for
like people who have not sure
anything got in the middle of
Adam? No, I'm just fucking,
I dunno what I'm looking for. What
do you got to offer? What's for sale?
I'm not sure what I want for lunch.
Once on the menu.
Anybody that'll take
any, uh huh. Yeah. Yeah.
But the desperation, the
desperation to, to hook up
crazy.
And another thing is I can tell the
comedians that do stand up comedy just to
get girls,
guys that didn't get laid in high school
and college that figure it out later on
that need a second.
If I make people laugh and I go on stage,
the people that do just for checks.
Yeah,
that's annoying to you guys.
I'm trying really hard to be an actual
standard. Right, right, right, right.
Exactly. Those guys never, right. Exactly.
We have the same bits and once
they have bits that work, they
stick to those fucking things
like glue forever and you're like,
where's your new shit man?
Never going to see it. Yup.
That's a trap, Huh? Yeah. Whenever you,
you think about other motivations
other than the work itself,
the work itself suffers, you know, they
said they had, they did this thing,
they did the study on motivations and
the motivation of doing good work versus
the motivation of just trying to make
money and they found that the least
success was achieved when you had a
combination of the both because then you'd
be really distracted. The least
results. The worst results were,
were when someone was like,
I want to do good work,
but I want to make a lot of money. So
how do I do the work, make it good,
but try to make a lot of money.
Like that is the worst results.
And the best results were achieved when
they didn't think about the money at all.
But concentrated entirely on doing
good work. Yeah, no doubt about it.
I mean, I was always,
you know, the first, uh,
three or four years of me doing stand up,
moving out here,
I came out here with a carry on bag and
like $40 cash rolled into a job at a
restaurant, you know, but
I, I had nothing, nothing,
nothing, nothing, nothing.
And had I,
when I started standup,
dwelled and thought about the fact that
I'm crashing on my brother's couch and
then, um, you know, then I was renting out
a couch in another buddy's living room.
You know what I mean? And had I thought
about how this isn't normal and the,
you know, this sucks. I never would've
been able to write another joke, but,
and I had to write everything.
Everything I've written,
I mean everything I wrote back then I
wrote while completely broken, struggling.
So it's like you got to just ignore it.
Isn't it fascinating though that you can
only really have that kind of position
when you're young, when you're young
people accept it, it seems normal,
but if you found out that a dude was 40
and he was living on his brother's couch
trying to make it as a comedian, you
like, oh, you poor piece of shit.
That's a different situation
for sure. I, you know,
really never found what I was
looking for until last year,
decided to quit my job, had
a job at ups, was a good job.
I was in sales and then boom,
it's poor guys on someone's couch trying
to grind it out as a standup comic.
Yeah. Can't do it then
for sure. It's hard.
Even when you're in the later twenties
start getting into your thirties and
people go, oh, come on man.
Right. It might be time to,
might be time to bail on this.
Yeah. Got To do something.
You've got to supplement that income
somehow. Yeah. To supplement the income.
That's one thing.
But the,
the idea of the grand struggle of
like trying to make it as an actor,
like say someone's 45,
they decided I'm going to be an actor.
Good fucking luck man. Good luck. Right?
You're gonna want to start at 45.
Jimmy fucking people are out
there trying to be actors, right?
Most 45 year olds are going
to be auditioning against
for the same part of a 45
year old had been acting for 25 years.
So yeah, they started off as a teenager.
I think luck of beating them
in your audition. You know,
that's one thing that we have that we're
so fortunate as a standup comic that
you create your own stuff, you
deliver your own stuff, you design it,
you execute it, you produce it, all
of it is done by Tony Hinchcliffe.
When you get up there, it's 100%
uh, Tony Hinchcliffe production.
Whereas like if you are even in a band,
you'd have to deal with all the other
dudes in the band. And you know, man,
when am I going to do my drum solo?
And like, this is fucking drum solo.
Having to do
decide the words of the lyrics
and when the, all that stuff,
that's why bands can't last at all.
All my buddies that were
supposed to be huge Rockstar,
uh,
the couple of friends that I had that
are gurus on an electric guitar can play
it. If I can just do this,
this behind the back,
everything and they can play anything.
There's Stelling, Youngstown,
rotating new band members every
one to two years. Hey, tell him,
check out my new band. This
is a computer box dreams. Hey,
check out my new band. This is a
Buddha's mystery. Check out my new band.
Brick wall extreme. You know, it's
like dude, brick wall. We stream.
We, yeah, it's like you
got to go solo, go solo,
get rid of these rooms and yeah,
it's tough. Uh, bands crazy.
You think of a movie people don't realize
every single credit that they see at
the end of a movie is somebody that
could have ruined the movie. You know,
almost everybody has, if they don't
pull their weight, if the, you know,
whatever the script supervisor sucks,
that could ruin a great editors work
or vice versa. You know what I mean?
Editor can ruin a director,
director can ruin a producer.
Everybody has to pull their
weight. Whereas with standup
it's a one man machine.
Yeah and it's also like
you, you, you travel light,
you don't need a bunch of shit that you
have to take with you to the airport.
Right. You know, you just,
it's, it's just so much,
it's still hard to do but at least you
get like you get undeniable like you,
you can get good.
Like there's guys that we know that are
totally broke that are open miker is
that hang around with us.
Like they're in the same group.
Like when you show up at the comedy clubs
and then their shows and there's open
Mike shows and there's regular
shows is bringer shows.
Like everybody interacts with each other.
We interact with guys that
are just starting out.
We interact with guys that had been doing
it for years and if you fucking good
man, if you get those three minutes
and you crush those three minutes,
people want to put you on your
show and it might take a few years,
but a couple years later, you know
you're crushing. You do in 10 minutes,
you're crushing, you're doing 15 minutes,
you're crushing it. You're, you're right,
you're, you're bombing. You come back
better. You, you crush you, right?
You keep doing it, you get
undeniable. But if you're in a band,
you're never undeniable,
right?
Because there's some music
that you are not interested in.
Like WWE, if you are a guy who wants
to be a fucking country music guy,
you can make music all day.
But if you're in the wrong place,
if they don't like your kind of
stuff like you and you're just not,
you can never become undeniable. But
if you, you can make people laugh.
It's pretty universal. If you're a good
comic and you have 300 people there,
those 300 people who might have widely
different tastes when it comes to what
kind of music they like,
what kind of food they eat,
but you can get all 300 of them.
The laugh with something they've never
heard before to get all 300 of them to
really truly enjoy a song.
Very hard.
Yeah. The Ah, it's,
it's tough working with other people.
That's really the thing.
Being in a band, it's hard, man.
I can't even imagine having to put
up with somebody artistic opinion for
everything that you're going to end
up representing somebody telling you
what they think.
Yeah.
I'm trying to text dom Irrera to see if
I can get him to send us that song so we
can close with it. What did he do? He
wrote a song. Yeah. Does he sing in it?
Yeah. And it sounds
really professional. Like,
like it sounds like a real song that you
would here. It's really weird. Really?
Yeah. Dom, I rera he looks
good, dude. I'm telling you.
I didn't even know he was in that realm
whatsoever. Did I? It sounds like a joke.
He's always been a Beatles fan. Oh yeah.
Yeah. I mean, he's always been into music,
but it's fucking good. Like wow.
I was like, Whoa, this is weird.
But he's such a good comic.
When someone's that good.
I would imagine that anything that
he does essentially could be great.
You know what I mean? I'll wait.
I want to do is focus on it.
Trying to get him to quit drinking.
Hmm. He, uh, he brought it up.
I didn't bring it up. He brought it up
yesterday. He's like, I drank too much.
I wake up every day drunk.
What's good?
Better than what he said the first time
he was on where he was talking about
pills all the time and stuff. Remember
that? Xanax. Xanax. Yeah. Still on that.
But he takes a Xanax in the morning and
then, uh, by the time the Xanax wears out,
that's when he hits the booze.
Wow.
He's so funny.
He's hilarious.
It was so fun having you and him on kill
Tony together at the ice house. Yeah.
We were talking about that.
We were talking about how
fun that is. Yeah, yeah.
That's the one of the most beautiful
thing also about comedy is the comradery
fucking around with other comedians. You
know, like when we're on the road, dude,
me mean we do all these
gigs together and it's,
it's annoying that you got to go to
airport to hotel to say, but it's fun.
We're laughing. Oh yeah.
Which save us Sacramento.
Oh yeah. I said a Sacramento is
a, is a puppy mill for porn stars.
Just where they,
they just kick 'em out.
These chicks just come out wearing little
sweat pants and say juicy on the back.
Cute little butts and too little of a
shirt strolling through the airport all
looking like they're taking the next
flight to la just to land directly in the
valley to this list.
Certain
when like
do you go to a Burbank if
you leave Burbank to Vegas,
like would you can play that game.
Which one's a stripper? Right?
You could play that game.
Which girls are going to the rhino.
It's like there's a lot of gals that like
live in La and go to Vegas and make a
shit ton of money there over the weekend
and then fly back to La and I'm not
hating, I'm not mad at him. Right.
But it's fun to pick them out. Yeah.
And it's pretty easy to,
they always wear a troopy sweatpants.
Like they're playing it down like we're
not supposed to notice. Yeah. Right. Yeah.
Yeah. They don't wear like sexy
clothes. Probably so tired. Yeah.
That dude's fucking stand at their
box. Right. Well all the ugly girls,
all the ugly girls, they try to dress
up and the those ones try to dress down,
but it's too obvious cause they try too
hard to dress down. I'm just wearing a,
you know, just wearing a hoodie and a
pair of sweatpants. Yeah. It's important.
They're there to giving up their hand.
Right.
But sweat pants are hot on a girl. Super
Cute. And you see that little butt flap,
you know, or the cloth like sorta curls
up right underneath the butt cheeks. Oh.
Karolin sweatpants is so much
better than a hot chicken jeans.
You know what I mean? I mean,
I'm saying both hot checks,
but I'm saying I'd rather,
I'd prefer hot chicken sweatpants
then genes cause it's not the same.
You can't feel that.
Well if you grab a girl's ass and
pants,
it feels like you're grabbing a girl's
ass where if you grab a girl's ass and
tight jeans, it's like you are holding
on to something that's restrained. Right.
You know, it's like, like
a straight jacket. Yeah.
Like you got a straight
jacket on your posting. Thick,
thick canvas. Straight jacket that you've
stubbed your fucking box into. Yeah.
You know your, your legs or skin
tight like girls never wear like,
like these kinds of genes like loose
jeans. Nobody wears those. Right?
They wear jeans where they can barely
walk. Yeah. They're just shoved into them.
Yeah. How often you see a girl
with baggy jeans? It's super rare.
I don't know. When is the last
time I saw Esther pivot ski?
I haven't heard a fucking peep about her.
What's going on with Little Leicester?
Last time marriage.
She was working up in Nicole Richie.
She's doing a lot of MTV
stuff. Isn't that right? Yeah.
Tony talks are more probably,
what is she doing? Uh, she's, uh,
she just made a pilot,
uh, and, um, she's, uh,
she's working it, just doing her
thing, doing spots at the store.
Okay.
What's the big pause and look down,
look up, pause, look down, look up.
Just admiring this glowing
rock. There's some, uh,
there's a, uh, uh, thing that
I tweeted earlier today that,
uh, in one of its kind study
in international team of
neuroscientists and robotic
engineers have demonstrated the viability
of direct brain to brain communication
and humans and recently
published and, uh, some,
some uh, study in p l o s one. Um,
it's the novel findings describe a
successful transmission of information via
the Internet,
but between the intacs scalps of two
human subjects located 5,000 miles apart.
Whoa.
Okay.
The one to find out if one could
communicate directly between two people by
reading out the brain activity from one
person and injecting brain activity into
the second person and to do so across
great physical distances by leveraging
existing communication pathways.
That's fucking nuts, man.
Whoa.
So what they're essentially saying is
through the Internet there's sending
information directly from brain to brain.
So what we were talking about earlier,
yeah,
that's real.
Like there they are literally going to
be able to directly transmit like I'm
going to be able to look at
you and send you a message.
I won't even be able to
say I have to say anything.
I'll send you a message and that
message is going to go to your brain.
Like I'll have an idea like
check out this mother fucker is.
It's going to show up in your brain.
Check out.
This motherfucker knew like exactly or
not even going to have control over over
thinking a hundred years from now
they're just going to create tools.
Who are they though?
They are going to be subject to the
same shit that we're subject to.
Like this idea that there's a giant
club ball of people that are going to be
able to control this.
That might be the most ridiculous
aspect of conspiracy theories.
One of the most ridiculous
aspect key thing really happened.
You said that and that's why
I'm wondering murder dude.
They murdered a bunch of people.
That's a lack of communication.
They killed people.
I mean,
this is in the nineties this
is pre internet that all
this shit went down. Right?
I mean it was,
the Internet is essentially what's
blowing back against them right now. Yeah,
but that's more like a fucking game
of Thrones type scenario, right.
Than it is someone not being
able to control information
software or information
technology like this. You know, this is
a completely different sort of a thing.
I just wonder, I wonder what we're going
to be like a thousand years from now,
we're going to be
completely unrecognizable.
The concept of what life is going to be
unrecognizable and the idea of privacy
is going to be hilarious.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's going to be hilarious.
Flooded. There's no privacy stop.
We're the last people to
experience privacy until
the, until something happens.
Until there's some sort of a crash,
like a civilization crash,
like asteroidal impacts super volcano,
massive earthquake,
some power shut down or
things go back to normal.
We're going to be the last
people that experienced privacy,
like real true privacy.
Yeah.
Have you ever gone somewhere where you
got no cell phone signal and like stayed
there for days? Yeah. Yeah.
Where Joshua tree, but he can get phones
out there and get cell phones out there.
Not, not with sprint.
You can't, is that true?
Do you guys with ATNT making calls?
Did you get jealous? Same thing.
It's same thing at the comedy store.
My phone barely works there. Yeah,
but that's cause the comedy
store is a vortex. Yeah.
There's something going on that you could
have full fucking four bars when you
drive up that high at parking lot and
then you look at your phone once you step
into the fucking hollowed
walls. So true. It is so true.
Is it the lead parking
lot? Parking lot, please.
There's nothing.
Did you know that Paul is trying to
get people to stop smoking pot there?
I heard a rumor of this.
I haven't seen it directly.
I actually talked to Paula yesterday
for a moment in the parking lot.
I'm pretty sure I was smoking
pot while talking to them.
Um, you know, he's Paulie,
he's a, he's a, he's a, he's,
he's a character man.
Indeed.
Sort of like Donald Duck or yeah.
Yeah.
Like the undertaker.
Are they really going to try to do that?
Try to get people to stop
smoking pot of the comedy club.
Absolutely impossible.
That is something that could never be
done at the comedy store at the last thing
they want is their entire uh,
line up out on the sidewalk smoking
pot because they're not allowed sees,
does smoke pot wherever they are.
Lousy how layer? Yes. Like a smoking
lounge like they do at the airport.
They do have a smoking
lunch at the comedy store.
It's called everywhere around the comedy
store and inside of it. But they,
maybe they should have like a look.
You have to have like a card. You Swipe
it and you have a little membership.
You go in to the hotbox
buddies in their barbecued,
you go in there like if
you ever pass those smoking
things, especially in Europe,
like you don't realize how much people
smoke in other countries. Holy Shit.
Like I was in Germany.
I took these photos of it cause it,
it didn't seem real and it
had all these warnings on it.
It's like this smoking station where you
could go into this literally this glass
box and they created at the airport.
He's people went and it was filled with
smoke. It was so bizarre. Like we stopped,
it was me and Eddie Bravo. We stopped and
we, uh, we looked at it, we were like,
look in there. This is crazy.
Like these fucking people are,
they're all like surrounding themselves
with each other's smoke and they just
sit in there.
It was a really creepy, I remember being
at the Denver airport or somewhere,
some airport a few years ago and I at
a layover and I saw one of those and I
went inside and it was exactly like
the waiting room from beetle juice.
Like all these creepy like people with
like something missing or like something
weird and they're just
slowly smoking is awful.
Remember that waiting room from beetle
juice for the guy sprinkles dust on the
guys head and it shrinks. Beetle
juice holds up by the way. Doesn't go.
God Michael Keaton. Michael Keaton's
best work. Tim Burton's best work,
perhaps Danny Elfman's.
Best word.
Well, Michael Keaton's best work. Um,
and you've seen Batman and this is right.
Yeah. Yeah. Well,
I'll send Tim Burton. I mean, they
went into that post beetle juice,
two different characters, by the way.
I mean like the, you know, the both,
both amazing works of art in two different
takes from Michael Keaton. You know,
two was the Michael Keaton one
where he played a dude. It was like,
there's a hundred of them.
It's so funny. Is it? Oh,
it's so fun. Good. Oh yeah.
What about, um, the other one,
Johnny dangerously? Yeah. Yeah. I
don't think I've seen that though.
Him and Joe Piscopo. I've heard good
things about it, but I don't think,
but I'll hook once.
Michael Keaton's lawn.
I read a great interview about him
yesterday. He lives in Montana now,
hunts every day. Has Dogs,
goes to diners, you know,
just lives a normal, cool life. And people
just sort of like, oh, nice to meet you,
Mr Kayden Yang.
Glad that you live in the neighborhood.
And he lives like this low profile,
but he hunts every day and writes and
is always on the phone and he's looking
for the next gig but doesn't want to do
any it take and just anything cause you
still act. Oh yeah. Huh. When he finds
the thing that he's interested in,
I haven't seen him in anything
in a long time. You know,
it's weird when you see
a guy like that and they,
they kind of fade out a little bit. Yeah.
Well he's Sorta Chelan. I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure he's a,
yeah.
I'm pretty sure he likes living
the mellow life showing us. Brian,
what is that?
That's Michael Keaton, the
movie. Yeah. That's what I
read is it say human foibles.
What human foibles give Birdman?
It's super human wing.
Foibles is a weird word to use. You ever
had anybody use it in a conversation?
I know what that means and I'm a wordsmith
and the writers need to be awards for
the don't know what foibles means. I
have no idea. I'm an honest word. Smith
foibles is a minor weakness or
eccentricity in someone's character.
They have to tolerate
each other's foibles.
Huh?
Jay, you don't remember this
part and uh, John that move,
we were just talking about
your testicles in you
and now I don't remember. I don't
remember Johnny dangerously that much.
It was really kind of remember
that now that I'm seeing it.
Yeah. It's just like guys
walking around with huge balls.
It's guys who are like,
Oh yeah,
this guys whose balls grow too big. So the
idea. Yeah, I think so. That is real man.
You ever seen those poor folks where
their ball swell up to the size of,
they've had them on television before.
He's got a weird nut
ball.
One Ball.
Does he ever gone to the doctor about
his ball mentions have rampant cancers
ignoring it?
I remember that video weight on the
end of June clam and it showed a,
and they had had like skittles in it.
It looked like a bunch of like weird.
No I don't, I don't have really any
intense recollections of his balls.
It was a weird time period.
You're saying are he's balls
look like they had skittles.
Yeah.
If you look at Geo clean,
did you taste the rainbow?
The Rainbow?
He couldn't help himself help
himself. Yeah, there's a, um,
I think he's in Michigan. Yeah. Who?
Michael Hayden Montana.
Is it Montana?
Yeah, I read the yoga is
amazing. Interview and Esquire.
Michael Keaton. I mean,
it's crazy. I couldn't believe how good
it was. So read it yesterday. Really? Ah,
so good. This guy's living a cool
life man, and he's just a cool dude.
This journalist, you know, explains
it. Like when I got the assignment,
here's what happened,
and I talked to Michael Keaton's manager
and here's what he told me I should
look into before I meet him.
Next thing you know,
I'm on a plane and Michael Keaton's
calling me at 6:30 AM like,
I hope it's not too early. I'll
meet you for lunch. Bobby Bell,
like Michael Keaton is just
the man pretty much, you know,
you're a big Fan,
huh?
Come on in. If anybody born in 1984,
if you don't like Michael Keaton,
then you know what?
Okay,
get out of the world. Go. Go for it.
Go to the ocean and
just swim the direction,
not of land, just keep swimming
until you're nothing. If you,
if you're anti Michael Keaton,
you're anti everything
that's good beetle juice.
The Best Batman multiplicity.
Is that a monster?
What does it mean? That movie he
played, uh, there was him and uh,
it was a couple that was renting
him and apartment and uh,
he didn't want to leave remembering
he was like some crazy scammer.
It was like a San Francisco is about
San Francisco because San Francisco has
like insane real estate. Remember
that? Yeah, I'll find it.
He um, yeah, it was like,
I forget the name of it,
but I think it was with a
dude from vision quest to,
did you ever see that movie vision
quest or the original vision quest?
The rest of the movie?
Yeah. Matthew Modine. Yeah.
Remember she didn't think he was in
that movie. Wow. Night shift. No.
No. Um, [inaudible] I
find that the squeeze,
it was like Pacific something or another
Pacific Heights. Yeah. Yeah. That's it.
That's it. That was a good fucking movie.
He's been reliable. He was in Noah's Ark,
the new beginning.
He was a voice of Noah.
What kind of a piece of shit was that
movie? Is that the one we watched? No,
we tried to watch.
You should say we tried to watch the
new Noah movie with Russell Crowe.
Holy Shit.
Shit was that bad.
And he only watched part of what was bad.
You didn't want you gave up?
Yeah, we all gave up Jamie game
up too. But I hung in there.
I fucking took more blows and
bolts. You I tapped. It was gross.
It was so bad. And then it got to like
sum, it became, at first it was like,
there was like monsters and stuff like
rock monsters and bad people and it was,
it was so like predictable and goofy.
But then when I got on the boat and
when they were dealing with the flood,
then it became like this weird, you know,
sort of like when walking dead
got all about people, you know,
and everybody got kind of bummed out.
It's just like interpersonal shit
between people. Yeah. That's what it is.
On this stupid boat with Noah.
You would think this story
would have a better arc, but
you send them a bit and help
yourself. Help yourself. I can't.
So what's new and Tony Hinchcliffe
slide. What's cracking? We got going on.
Fun Man. Just did it. Did
a lot of touring with you.
I'm really excited about
some little things coming up.
A little few writing projects that I
already sort of pitched and it's a waiting
for the good word for that, but really
I'm most excited about kill Tony.
I care about it a lot and I love it.
It should be a TV show.
I just love it. We're having
so much fun. Every Monday,
the last 10 episodes have been our best
episodes. It's running like a machine.
It's the room is packed.
Every Monday the there's buzz.
I feel like it's just
fun and cool and it's a
bringing it to Columbus, Ohio to, yeah.
Are you guys going to do it live? Yeah.
Now when you do it live, you
can use local comics. Yeah.
How many comics do you have in
Columbus? A lot. Yeah. I'm on me.
When I used to do open mic there,
there was at least 50 comics
that would sit there and all.
We would all have to audition in front
of other comics just to do three minutes.
No Shit. 50. Yeah, there was a
lot back then. Wow. I had no idea.
So many people uh, you know, asks,
I get a tweet a day at least. Hey,
bring it to Vancouver. How
are you, how do you pick,
like if for folks who don't
know how the show works,
everybody goes up and does a minute. How
many comics do you have on our show? A,
well usually about 20 to 30 sign up and
usually about 12 to 15 get on and you
decide how many go on,
how just it just depends.
See the part that's the part of the format
that's a little bit more loose is how
long we spend on each person is totally
dependent on how we feel with them up
there.
You know,
for folks who don't all the person that
was a minute and then the professional
comics goof on them. Oh,
we talked to them about,
and maybe maybe we try to coax them
into writing a new bit by asking them
questions about their life,
where they're from, Bobby ba or,
or font or goof on them.
Right. We had a guy wearing a,
what looked like cum stain shorts
on first, first day. He's like,
I came here all the way from Tuscaloosa,
Alabama to do my first set of stay in
bed and he's like wearing these terrible
shorts.
And of course I'm going to light him up.
He probably lives in silver
lake and its characters. Yeah.
I'm working on is probably totally fake.
Yeah. It's probably a hipster. Right?
It's just fucking with you just decided
to like make an art piece out of doing
like really bad obvious standup.
We used to make fun of people a lot
harder. Really? Yeah. What changed?
Death threats? No violence itself. No,
I think the show is a little bit cooler
and more positive and I found something
that I found out through the show because,
you know,
I like making fun of people and roasting.
It's definitely a part of my, uh,
whatever toolbox. But, uh,
I think the show organically grew.
I think it's more satisfying to give to,
for somebody to come up with something
that's genuinely funny and only they can
do and try to figure out what that is
and a short allotted amount of time.
It's like watching a baby, being born like
a little comedy baby, like if you know,
whatever the guys in
Indian guy from whatever,
and it turns out to be gay.
I don't know.
We just had Sinbad also on recently
and Jeff Garlin, which was,
you guys did that at the comedy
store, right? Yeah. Nice. Yeah,
we did. We've done most of
the episodes out of there
every Monday eight o'clock
comedy store and if anybody wants to sign
up how far in advance they have to get
there that day, that day. Yup.
Just show up. Do it. Just show up.
That's the same way with open
Mike there. Right. And still, Yup.
It's one of the few places like that
I like, um, the laugh factory sign up,
but you have to wait in line and then
you're waiting in line for like the next
week, right? Yeah. Yeah.
Just so crazy. Yeah.
Let's just torture people are going
to work for free for you, right?
Yeah. Well the idea is like to make
them work hard for some reason. Yes.
Make them earn it. Yeah.
I don't, I don't get it.
They could just as easily
have them go up that day.
And why do you have to have
them wait in line, you know,
make them sign up and then
pick from the people there.
It's not the same reason.
The laugh factory does everything that
they do because they think a line outside
of their place makes them
look busy. That's how they
do it. That's why they don't,
they'd rather not sell drinks on a patio
or an a back bar and upstairs or in
anything.
They'd rather make it look like it's
busy by putting a little line around the
front. That's their whole trek.
Yeah. Oh yeah. We got there.
So there's something happening. Look,
there's people waiting on a sidewalk.
You know, those are young comic standing
in 95 degree heat for no reason.
For five hours a day. Literally for
hours and hours. People will get there.
Yeah, I've passed by there. Uh,
I did Don [inaudible] podcast and it was
during the day and there was a bunch of
people that were there also.
Actually Eliza as podcasts I did out
of there recently during the day was a
bunch of people.
They're just sitting there for no fucking
reason and they have to stay there,
which is like insuring someone that
they can't make a living. Right?
Like you don't require anything of that.
I'm, why are you making them stay there?
Right. How hard is it? Jesus. Jamie
Masada. There's two days in a row.
We've been talking shit about you.
Yeah,
give a mile. It's the first 15
people or whatever. They get there,
but they'll make them wait all day.
Body
is very important by the,
we have to get them to sit in the,
we have system we teach, we
teach them. They do good job.
They do what we tell them
on the podcast. Joe? Nope,
I did a podcast with him and Dom
Arrera if you want to listen to it.
I love Jamie.
Don't get me wrong.
I do love the guy and the guy he
is responsible for keeping open.
One of the top clubs in the country in
that club is one of the best clubs in La,
which makes it one of the best clubs in
the country. Are you making that face?
Which I'm sorry.
No, no, I don't like
it. You don't like it?
I don't think the color is yellow and
blue and orange belong anywhere near
cause you're a dark man with a dark soul.
You Damn right baby.
That's why you should be dressed in gold,
dancing around going,
hey andro take a streak as my brows.
So silly. You're right though. To
something about comedy, like dark,
dark seems to be like, yeah, give
me a low ceiling pitch. Black, dark.
Just a mic and a mic. Stand. A stool.
That's all I fucking want. Red Kurt.
Speaking of which you're going
to be at the comedy works,
you're going to get a date there to
headline after you a work there with him.
Yeah. Amazing. Yeah. I was
so happy I picked that place.
She's, that's the spot. Yeah.
Wendy's awesome. She really is. Yeah.
But that,
that club is also like the perfect setup.
Like literally the
perfect setup for totally
hanging out with her was really
interesting because uh, you know,
I, I never really got to
hang with Mitzi and you know,
I know it's two different
people and everything,
but the amazing maternal energy that I
felt from her and like love of standup
comedy made me feel like I sort of got
it from like being a comedy store guy,
but in a post Mitzi era.
Like it was amazing to get to hang
with powerful comedy woman like that.
Yeah. She's awesome. Yeah.
There's only a few people like that in
the country that are responsible for
scenes. You know, like the,
the comedy scenes in cities can be
directly dependent upon like a single club
sometimes. Like cap city is like
a big one for Austin. Right.
That's another place we worked at
recently that that's like the hub.
That's the big spot in Austin
that is the big club in Austin,
Texas and there's like a few of
those all across the country.
It's a kind of amazing that they haven't
like tried to move in with an Improv in
Austin. Like how, how's the
Improv missed on Austin, Texas?
You mean they have one in
Houston but it doesn't,
it's kind of an a sketch neighborhood
apparently, but there's no more other,
like there's no more independent
club in Houston anymore.
They used to be the last stop, which is
like the one of the greatest of all time.
And that club, the laugh stoppers
responsible for Bill Hicks,
Sam Kinison,
even Janeane Garofalo I think did
a lot of her early stuff out of,
uh, out of the last stop. It was just
a completely different kind of club.
And that one club like defined
that whole town's comedy scene,
Houston at one point in time,
it was like one of the best
comedy scenes in the country.
Like some of the best up and coming young
talent was coming out of Houston was
weird.
But that club goes under that one club
goes under and then the whole thing just
kind of like drifts off. It's
hard. It's hard to keep a scene.
So when you find someone like Wendy,
you gotta appreciate the fuck out of them.
Yeah, and I loved that. You
know what I mean? I mean,
any, anybody who had seen me
talking a bunch of crazy dark,
evil stuff before you and go, hey, you're
cool. You want to do a weekend here?
Like it's like,
wow,
we're talking about you're funny.
Yeah. But you know, everybody's always
looking for an excuse. Why to not,
even though it's funny, it's like if
everybody is always like, ah, you know?
Yeah. So dark. You know? Why don't
you, why don't you do some more
saying so dark? You're just
funny, man. You know it's not,
it's not like it's disgusting or
something ridiculous. Like, do you, you,
you looking down on your
own act or something? Like
what he'd done like so dark,
so dark.
I just can not that dark.
Well, I always get told, oh,
people's theories on
why this and why that,
I don't know why things aren't happening.
Right. What are you talking to? Agents.
Managers. Yeah. Those, those people. You
shouldn't, you shouldn't talk to them.
You know what? My manager told me the
other day, please tell me. He goes,
you need to, you need to not be so much
of a wrestling villain. Like you're like,
you're like a pro wrestling villain
and I don't think that goes well with
standup comedy. Nobody's ever done
that before. And I go, Gee, here,
you just said, I go, nobody's ever
done that before. You just said it.
He's an idiot. You got a new
one, your manager. I can't,
I can't tell someone that
too much of an anything.
He doesn't have any idea why you're funny.
No one has any idea why you're funny other
than, you know, it sounds ridiculous,
but you're absolutely right.
The only people that can help you or
other pro comics that work with you that
kind of see things, they will. Maybe
if you're this or maybe if you're that,
and then you take it into consideration
and knowing it's coming from someone who
actually knows what they're talking about,
but someone who's never done stand up
trying to tell you what does or does not
make you funny. They can't
do it. They can't do it.
It's just a wasted conversation,
buddy. You should be generation x guy.
Go on stage.
Everything come out of your
mouth is about generation X.
Jamie Masada actually said
that to one of my friends.
You know what Jamie told me? I've told
you this right? I have the best one ever.
Yes, please. You still have to do the, Oh,
you would wait for hours to do the open
mic and then you go in everybody if you
willing to do that,
if you stick around after the open mic,
you can go up to Jamie and eaten
the owner of the land victory.
Jamie will give you his advice
on your career. What he said.
Yeah Buddy Buddy. Very
funny. You wear a cowboy hat.
Do you make it to come back with
cowboy hat? They put you on stage.
So did you,
I took,
I didn't, I didn't go back
as a cartoon. It's me.
You're gonna die.
Did you think about it like thinking
if you came back with the cowboy hat at
least you'd get another spot.
No, that'd be a funny bit.
If you had a fucking cowboy hat
that you kept in your trunk,
just we do the laughter.
Right. Gotcha. Great idea.
Fucking Jamie.
Hey, it's Tony Hinchcliffe. Hey, I took
your advice. Got The hat. Cowboy hat.
Shit's been booming. Do you
ever do the laugh factory? Yeah,
do it when I would do dom show.
I'm doing it next Tuesday
before I do a Ari's a TV show.
I'm going to warm up at the
laugh factory Tuesday night.
Tell my story at the laugh factory
and then go do a sorry story show next
Tuesday. The ninth in Hollywood
is pat will be in town. Yeah.
All Right Ladies and gentlemen
is fuck podcast over.
You could find Tony
Hinchcliffe on Twitter.
His Twitter handle is Tony Hinchcliffe.
It should say super twink in the title,
but it does not.
I don't understand. I've went looking,
but it just doesn't seem to be up there.
Super twink
come see me. Red Band and Tiffany Haddish
in Michigan. Uh, Columbus and Phoenix.
Phoenix and NX. Yeah. So look for this.
Yeah, go to death squad. Dot
TV for all that information.
Uh, Tony Hinchcliffe is t,
O, n, y, H, I, N, C H, c l, I f, F,
e on Twitter and a,
what's your website,
Tony hinchcliffe.com and please
listen to the Kell. Tony,
if you haven't listened to kill Tony,
why don't you start with your
pal Joe Rogan and dom Irrera.
I believe it's episode 48 for some reason.
Enjoy it. Yeah, you're fucks.
And uh, thanks to our sponsors.
Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you to zip recruiter.
Go to ziprecruiter.com/rogan and you
can post jobs for free by going to
ziprecruiter.com forward slash Rogin and
with one click you can get your job up
at 50 plus job sites, including
craigslist, linkedin, and Twitter,
all with a single click.
So thank you to them.
And thanks also to draft kings.
Go do draft kings.com entering
the codeword Rogan to get
a free entry into week
one,
$5 million kick off bash.
What did I say? I said $5
million. You dirty. Fuck.
So go to draft kings.com
enter in the Promo Code Rogan,
and thanks also to onnit.com
that's o. N. N. I. T,
used the Codeword Rogan and save 10%
off any end, all supplements. All right.
We'll be back next week. Until then.
Enjoy your life. You'd already fucks.
Yes.